bootstrap is one of the most popular css
frameworks
and sas is one of the most popular css
preprocessors
in this course patrick will teach you
how to create a portfolio website
using bootstrap 5 and sas hey
everyone how you doing thanks for
checking out this video my name is
patrick from vex accord
so in this video we're going to build a
multi-purpose layout with bootstrap
version 5
and sas and the first thing you're going
to do is to learn how to set up the sas
environment
so that can be able to work with sas
then you're going to start building the
project for a company called patrick's
so we're going to start with the navbar
which is the topmost part of this
layout and then you're going to create a
second section called the intro section
so here you're going to create a brief
introduction about the company
and then on the right you're going to
create this pop-up so you have this
animated play button and once you click
then a video will pop up from youtube or
any other source that you choose from
they're going to create another section
called services so we're going to
showcase some of the services
our fake company is offering from there
going to create another section called
testimonials so we're going to showcase
what our clients are saying about
the company and then from there we're
going to create another section called
frequently asked questions so here we're
going to use
bootstrap component called accordion
so once you click then the question
collapses and
reveals the answer from there we're
going to create another section
for latest work so here going to
showcase some of the latest work of a
company is
has created and then we have these
filtering buttons
for filtering the categories for the
portfolio from there we're going to
create another section called get
started
so this one is similar to what you call
call to action so we have this form
and then finally we have the bottom part
of the layout which is the
footer then from there going to make
sure that our layout is fully responsive
across variety of screen devices
so before we get started make sure you
have some basic knowledge
in html and css so stick around and
let's get started
welcome back in this video we are going
to set up the sas environment
and this is to make sure that we have
the correct environment for working
with sas so the first one is to install
node.js it's an open source server
environment
nodejs allows you to run javascript on
the server and it's free and it runs on
various platforms
so if your machine is not yet installed
with node.js you can head over to the
office website which is nodejs.org
so here on the homepage for those who
are using windows we have a download
recommended for most users and this one
is more than enough
for this project alternatively you can
also download the current one which has
the latest features
for other platforms like linux and mac
you can check on this link that says
downloads so here you need to download
the one compatible with your platform
or operating system and then once you
download then you can install it
on your machine and once you install
then you need to open your terminal
and run node minus minus version
and this command will enable you to
confirm whether your machine is
installed with
node.js alternatively you can also use
node minus v so you can see mine is
installed with version 15.50
it can be different in your case but
make sure you see results like this
so if you don't see results then it
means your your machine is not yet
installed with
node.js so once you do that then we are
ready to move to the next step
and that is to create a file called
package.json
so this is a file which is going to help
us manage all the dependencies or the
packages that we're going to use
on the entire project so first we need
to
create a folder which is going to keep
our project files
so on my desktop
i'm going to create that folder so new
folder and i'm going to call this folder
bootstrap minus
v5 for version 5
and then i'm going to open that folder
and i'm going to open
my terminal or terminal inside that
project folder
so right click open in terminal so i'm
using git bash
and here you can see now i'm inside my
project folder and this is the path to
that folder
so here i'm going to run a command which
is going to initialize the process of
creating that file called package.json
so that command is npm init for
initialize
so this one is a step-by-step process of
creating that file
so hit enter so here you'll see it says
this utility will lock you through
creating a package.json file
it only covers the most common items and
tries to guess
sensible defaults so the first item here
is the package name and you can see it
has already assigned the name of that
folder
which is bootstrap minus v5 that is the
name of the folder that you're going to
keep all our projects
so if you're not comfortable with that
name then you can type that name
for example let's say you want a name
like
my project then you can type it there
and then hit enter
so for me i'm comfortable with that name
so that is the name of that
package name and then you can also have
the option to change the version
so i'm comfortable with that description
i'm going to write
learning bootstrap
version 5 with sas
the next item entry point test command
we're going to put it later
git repository later keywords so here
you can enter as many keywords as you
want separating them with comma
or space so i'm going to start with the
first keyword which is boost drop
space
boot strap
minus v5 space
we have sas space
lan bootstrap
space and then lan sas so one word
so i'm comfortable with those five
keywords actually four
five sorry and then i'm going to hit
enter
other that should probably be your name
or your company name
so i'm going to write my name
enter a license and then here the items
you need to double check
so if you're comfortable then you can
hit enter for ok
so now we have completed that process
and now if you check inside our project
folder you'll see we have a file called
package.json
the next step that i'm going to do is to
add or install the packages that you're
going to use
in our project so we're going to start
with the first package which is that sas
that's us is a preprocessor it's going
to help us compile sas to css
and then we're going to install
bootstrap of course and then
we have font awesome this one is going
to help us with the icons
and then we have the auto prefixer so
the auto prefix is a plugin that saves
you the monotony of adding prefixes to
your css
so let's start with that sas so you can
go to this website which is npmjs.org
and search for that package
alternatively you can also go to github
and search for
that sas so here on the search bar i'm
going to type
that hyphen sas
and by doing that you'll be able to see
the results and we need the result that
says a pure device
javascript implementation of sas so i'm
going to click on that
and here you'll see the first thing is
this package has been
duplicated that means the package has
been renamed to sas
so earlier it was named as that sas but
now it's been renamed to
sas so if you scroll down here on the
usage there are different ways of
installing and using
this package depending on your needs and
your environment
so you can see here you can install it
globally using npm install minus gsas
which will provide access to the sas
executable you can also edit your
project by using npm install
and because you're using npm then you're
going to install it using this command
so i'm going to copy that command
and then copy and then on the terminal
first i'm going to clear
and then i'm going to paste
enter so by doing that you'll be able to
see a new folder on our project folder
called node modules which is going to
keep all the packages that you're going
to install
so now as you can see we have that
folder and if you look on the terminal
you can see it has added 16 packages
so let's look again on the node modules
that folder
you'll see we have
that is some folders you can see we have
some folders the 16 of them
so i'm going to open this project on my
vs code
and here you'll see we have a new dev
dependency
on the package.json file so this one is
sas version 1.32 0.12
so that is the but by the time i was
doing this video it can be different by
the time you're watching this video
so the next package you're going to
install
so we have bootstrap so you could go to
the official documentation which is
getbootstrap.com so on the homepage here
you'll see
currently version five and then if you
scroll down here you'll see
the command that you're going to use to
install bootstrap
so down here we have the installation
and here you can see we have that
command npm install
bootstrap so i'm going to copy that
command
and then on the terminal i'm going to
paste
and then i'm going to flag it with minus
minus save
so this one will save it as a dependency
so it has added that package now if you
look on the text editor you'll see we
have
a new dependency called bootstrap
version 5.
so the next package you're going to
install is font awesome
so you can go to the official website
which is fontosam.com
and then down here you need to click on
start for free so i'm going to click
that
and then if you scroll down here you'll
see we have npm
so i'm going to click on npm
and then you'll see version 5.153 so
this is the version that we're going to
use
and then using this package we have
different ways of using it
and here we have the command for
installing it so you can see we have npm
installed minus miner save
and then the name of that package which
is font awesome
free so i'm going to copy that command
and then on my terminal first i'm going
to clear
and then i'm going to paste
enter so you can see it has added that
package
now if you check on the text editor you
can see we have a new
dependency called font awesome version
5.153
the next package that i'm going to
install is auto prefixer
so you can go to npmjs.com and search
for that package
so on the search bar i'm going to type
auto
prefixer and i'm going to click on the
first results
that says pass css and add vendor
prefixes to css rules using values from
can i use website so i'm going to click
on that
and here you'll see we have this
autoprefixer
post css plugin to pass css and add
vendor prefixes to css rules
so if you scroll down you'll see we have
the command for installing
this package
so i'm just going to to search for that
so i'm going to type
install
so you can see we have that command so
i'm going to copy
and then on the terminal i'm going to
paste
then i'm going to flag it with minus
minus save
enter so it has added
the packages nine to one packages so we
check from the text editor you see now
we have two
new dependencies we have the auto prefix
version 10
0.25 and we have post cli post css cli
version 8.31
so with that we can start working on our
project
and we are going to install other
packages
as the need arises then from there the
next step is to create
an npm script which is going to compile
our sas to css
so on the scripts you can see we have a
predefined script so i'm going to remove
it and then i'm going to write
my own so the first option on the script
is the name of that script so we have
the double quotes
and then the name of that script so i'm
going to call it compile
colon and then sas and here you have the
option to give it
any keyword or name that you want to use
then from there we have the command
again we have the double quotes
and you're going to start with sas the
name of that
package that we installed called the
datsus and then space
and then the source of your sas files so
i'm going to create a folder called
scss which is going to keep all the sas
files and then you have the column and
then the destination
of where you want to keep your compile
css so here i'm going to
tell the script to create two folders
the first one is the assets
and then the second one is css
so it's going to get my sas from the sss
folder and then it's going to compile
and keep that compile css to this folder
called css
so from there i'm going to save
and then i'm going to create this folder
called scss
so inside the project
i'm going to create that folder which is
scss
so from there we're going to put our
script to test so inside the css folder
i'm going to create a new sas file
and i'm going to call it style dot
scss
so on the terminal before we write any
style
i'm going to start that script
so on the terminal i'm going to run npm
run compile sas
so remember the name of that script if
you check again on the package.json file
you can see we have that
the name of that script which is
compiled call on sas
so that's the script that you need to
run on your terminal that is
npm run and then the name of that script
which is compile sas
it can be any name that you've given so
from there i'm going to hit enter
and by doing that you'll see it has
compiled and then terminated the process
and then if you check on the project
you'll see we have a new folder called
assets
and say and then inside that's it we
have another folder called css
and you can see we have the two files we
have style.css and then we have
a source map and source maps are files
that tell browsers or other tools that
consume css
how that css corresponds to the sas
files from which it was generated
so they make it possible to see and even
edit your sas files
in browsers so that means every sas file
that we create inside the sss folder
is going to generate a source map inside
the folder where we keep all the
compiled css
so for testing purposes i'm going to
write some styles on the sas
file which is the style.css
and then you're going to see how it's
going to compile on the style.css
so i'm going to open that file which is
style.css to the side
so that you can see in real time how
it's going to compile
so before i write any styles i'm going
to run
the script again
and here you can see it has compiled and
then it has terminated the process
so we need to keep this script running
every time that we do changes
to the sas file or to that folder called
scss
so to make it work we're going to modify
the script a bit so inside the package
to json file
we're going to modify the script again
and then we're going to add the watch
flag so that
it can watch for the changes that you're
going to do inside that file
or inside that folder called scss
so here on the script where we have the
sas
i'm going to create a space and then i'm
going to add that
flag which is minus minus watch
so that flag is going to watch for the
changes that you're going to do
inside that folder or any for any file
inside that folder called
sss so i'm going to save
and then i'm going to run the script
again
so now you can see the script has not
terminated the process you can see
sas is watching for changes you can
press ctrl c
to stop the script so you can see now
it's watching for the changes that
you're going to do inside that
file so let's do some styles
on that sas file and then you're going
to see how it's going to compile in
real time so here i'm going to create a
variable called primary
and then i'm going to assign the value
or a hex value that is
a red color so we have ff and the four
zeros
and then i'm going to assign it so we
have
a class called test one
i'm going to assign it a color
and then i'm going to assign it that
primary color
so immediately i save you'll see it's
going to compile
or watch for the changes and then
compile it to our style sheet
so i'm going to save and as you can see
it has compiled and assigned that color
so if we check now on the terminal
you'll see
it has already compiled and it's still
watching for the changes
that you're going to do so let's change
let's change the color
let's change to another color
so i'm going to assign it
a yellow color so we have ff0 and then
i'm going to save
and as you can see it has already
compiled and that means
it is watching for the changes that
you're going to do inside that
file so that means our script is working
perfectly fine so and just like i said
this one
was just for testing purposes so i'm
going to remove it
and then i'm going to save again as you
can see on the style
nothing to compile the next step that
i'm going to do is to customize
bootstrap
so here you're going to override some of
the bootstrap defaults so that you can
achieve the needs that you want
on the project i'm going to create a
custom source file
which is going to keep all the variables
that you're going to override in
bootstrap
and this is because it is not good
practice to modify or edit the bootstrap
call files
so inside the sss folder and this is the
folder that we said you're going to keep
all the sauce files i'm going to create
that
file so i'm going to create it as a
passion that means it will have an
underscore
and the underscore lets us know that the
file is only a partial and should not be
generated
into a style sheet so we have the
underscore and then custom
dot ss
so inside this file you're going to do
copy some of the
variables that you're going to override
including the bootstrap itself
so before you do the overage you're
going to import bootstrap
and then you're going to see some of the
changes that you're going to do inside
this file called demingkit.html
so this is the file that you're going to
see the changes that you're going to
override
it has some of the bootstrap components
like the navbar which are using some of
the primary colors
we have things like buttons which are
using some of the primary and the
secondary colors
and then we have things like tables we
have borders
and then if you scroll down here you
have alerts so some of these components
are using
the bootstrap variables that you're
going to override
so first let's import the bootstrap and
then you're going to link this file with
the style sheet
so we have the comment which is import
bootstrap 5
and then i'm going to import it using
the import add rule
so you have the imports
so we have node modules and then you
have bootstrap
and then scss and then you have
bootstrap.css so this is the mains file
or the main booster file which has
everything
and then close it with a semicolon then
from there we're going to import this
custom source file to our main sas file
which is the style dot
ss so i'm going to open that file and
then you're going to import it
and use it as a module so here we have
the use
patrol and then custom
and then i'm going to close that with a
semicolon and then i'm going to save
then i'm going to open this style.load
css to the side
we're going to see how it's going to be
compiled in real time
as you can see it has already compiled
and now this is our style sheet
so we're going to link that style sheet
to the dimming kit so i'm going to paint
that file
and then on the head section i'm going
to
link that stylesheet so we have the
assets
css and then style.css
so remember this file is available in
the description if you want to follow
along
on this part so i'm going to save and
then i'm going to go live
and check on the browser how it looks
like
so this is our file the gamingkit.html
you can see
some of the defaults like the primary
color is blue
which is being used here on the navbar
you can see the navbar is using that
primary color as the blue
and that is the defaults so we have
things like buttons
we have a lats we have table border we
have both
uh button borders so these are some of
the things
or some of the defaults that you're
going to override
using this file and you're going to see
some of these
changes in this file
so remember here we're going to do the
overrides
for the primary color and replace the
blue without primary colors which is
purple
and the pink color then from there going
also to do the
over it for the accordion button you can
see this button you need to replace that
with our plus icon so if you scroll down
here on the
testimonials you can see now
you're going to replace this button
which is the defaults to
the plus and the dash cycle
so you can see the default on the
bootstrap we have this chevron up
and the chevron down so you're going to
override some of those defaults
and this file is going to help us see
some of the changes that you're going to
do
so the next thing now to do is to copy
some of the
things that you want to override the
colors remember here
we have used the blue the blue is the
default
so we're going to copy them from the
bootstrap variables file which can be
found inside the node modules
and then we have the bootstrap scss
and then down here we have the variables
file
so i'm going to open that so here you
can see the primary color is assigned to
that blue
color as the default so i'm going to
start with the
gray colors and the white color so i'm
going to copy the entire
gray white and black colors
to my custom
so first i'm going to write a comment
white and
gray colors
so then again we need to remove the
default flag
once you copy you must remove the
default flag so i'm going to select all
of them
and then save so let's copy also
the primary so that we can assign it our
theme colors the one we have used in our
layout so before you copy the primer we
need to copy also the purple
and the pink colors
and that one i'm going to copy them at
the top of that file
so my theme colors
paste and then
let's copy also the primary and the
secondary color
so those are the two colors that we need
others can remain as default
so here we're going to sign i'll provide
color to that
purple
and then for a secondary color we're
going to change that
to the pink color
so also this one we need to remove the
defaults
and then i'm going to save we are going
to see the real changes
so now as you can see our theme they
make it has changed the colors
so now from blue to purple and also a
secondary color from greyhound
900 to the pink so but this is not the
color that you have used
in our layout so again if you check from
our layouts
so we have this purple and this pink and
these are different
hex values so i have them here on my
notepad so we're going to
assign them to our gray color and our
pink color
so let's start with the purple and this
one i'm going to modify a bit i'm going
to call it
purple dark because i have two colors
so i'm going to duplicate that and then
change from
dark to light so for the first color
i have it here this is my theme color so
i'm going to copy
paste we have the second color
copy
paste and then the pink color
copy
paste and then here we need to assign
that color which is
purple duck and then i'm going to save
let's see the overheads in our naming
kit.html
so you can see now our dimming kit has
reflected the colors that we have
changed
so these are the colors that are used on
our layouts
so again if you check here from the
layout
we need to do another override and that
is
the accordion buttons for collapsing so
you can see here
the default is what we have here on the
demikit we have this
this chevron app and then the chevron
done so we need to replace that with our
custom
buttons which is the plus and
the dash circle
so just like we did with the colors i'm
going to do the overrides for the
accordion variable
so let's copy that variable to our
custom
so inside the variables i'm going to
search for that accordion variable
so i'm going to write accordion
and here you'll see we have a number of
accordion variables
so first i'm going to copy the variables
responsible for the colors of the icons
and here we have the accordion icon
color and another one which is accordion
icon active color
so these are the two variables
responsible for the icon colors
so i'm going to copy the two and then
inside my custom first i'm going to
write a comment
so we have the accordion
overrides
and then for the accordion icon color
i'm going i'm going to assign it to our
primary color
so that is the primary variable
and then for the active icon i'm going
to assign it
our secondary color so that is the
secondary
variable
then we're going to copy another
variable which is
the variable for the icons so we have
the two variables which is the
accordion button icon which has this svg
icon for the chevron app
so if you look properly here you'll see
we have the svg
code for that
chevron app and then for the active icon
we have the chevron down so i'm going to
copy the two
variables and then you're going to
replace
the icons with the plus icon and the
dash circle
so inside the custom
i'm going to replace and then remove the
default flag
and then you're going to replace this
svg
code with the plus icon code
so the question is where are we going to
get the svg code so there are so many
sources that you can get the svg code
but i highly recommend that you use the
bootstrap icons
so you can go to icons.getbootstrap.com
so here you're going to search for the
icons that you're going to replace with
the default which is the chevron app and
chevron down
so here i'm going to start with the
first icon
for the chevron app and i'm going to
replace that with the plus icon so i'm
going to
just type plus
so here you'll see the different
versions of the plus icon
and we are only interested with the one
with the circle and we have the plus
circle
so i'm going to click on that icon
and here you'll see the different ways
of using this icon and you're only
interested
with the svg code so i'm going to copy
the html
code for that icon
and then i'm going to paste it on my
notepad
so here we're going to replace the
dimension
code so i'm going to copy for there you
have you can see here we have the two
path
so i'm going to copy the path for the
first dimension
or the dimension for the first path and
then
i'm going to replace the chevron up
so where we have the dimension only
replace that i'm going to select it
and then paste then i'm going to copy
the second path the entire path
and then again i'm going to paste it
here and then
you need to remove the double quotes and
replace that with a single quote
double quote replace that with a single
quote
i'm going to save that file and then i'm
going to check
from our dimming kit so here you can see
it has already replaced
or done the override for that icon you
can see now we have the plus
circle so let's go ahead and replace the
second one which is the chevron down
with the
dash circle so again just like we did
you're going back to
the search and you're going to search
for that circle
or for that circle so here i'm going to
type
dash circle
so we have the dash circle and here we
have it
so again you have different ways of
using this icon we are only interested
with html code for that svg
so copy again on my notepad
so just like we did i'm going to copy
the dimension only for the first path
and then again i'm going to replace for
the second
icon which is the chevron down
paste
and then they copy the second part the
entire path
and then again here paste remove the
double quotes
and replace that with a single quote
single quote and then save so let's see
the overage on our dimming kit
and there you have it you can see it has
replaced that
now we have the dust circle for the
active
and the plastic for the
inactive icon so i think we're done with
that part
the only thing we can do is just add
some
we can increase the font size of the
icon so again you're going to copy the
variables
or the variable for that icon
so here on the variables file you can
see we have that variable for that
icon width so i'm going to copy the
accordion icon width
copy to a custom
so i'm going to replace the default
which is 1.255 ram
with 1.875 ram
save check on the browser
and there you have it you can see now
it has increased the wind of the icon
and that is exactly what we have on our
layouts
so i think we are done with that part
welcome back in this video we are going
to create the file structure for our
project
and this is to make sure that we have a
code that is well organized and
maintainable
so i'm going to create all the sas files
for the sections and the components
so on the sss folder i'm going to create
the two folders
so the first folder i'm going to keep
all the sas files for the sections
and the second folder i'm going to keep
all the sas files for the components
links like buttons make sense and
animations and so much more so let's
start with the first folder which is the
sections folder so inside the sss folder
we have the sections
and another folder also inside the sss
folder
and this one we're going to keep all the
search files for the components
so let's start by creating the sas files
for the components and i
am going to start with the first one
which is the button so
apache underscore buttons dot
ss
so we're going to keep all the code for
the buttons on that file
another file or another component file
and this one we're going to keep all the
animations so underscore
animations dot scss
another file or another component file
and this one
we're going to keep all the mixins
so underscore makesense.css
also another source file or another
component file
and this one you're going to keep all
the typography so
underscore typography
dot ss
so i think we're done with the
components let's create the sas files
for the sections
so the first section is the number again
underscore
navbar.css
so that is our first section of the
layout
so let's see the second section which is
the intro section
so underscore intro section
dot scss
let's see the that one so the third one
we have this section
for the trusted by companies like so i'm
going to call it companies
so we have underscore companies
dot scss
so we have the fourth section which is
the our services
or the services section
underscore services
dot scss
so another section which is
the testimonials
so underscore testimonials.css
another section which is the frequently
asked questions
so again underscore faq dot scss
another section which is the latest work
i'm going to call it portfolio
and that's called portfolio dot
scss another section
which is the cts section i'm going to
call it get started
so underscore get started
dot scss
and finally we have the last section
which is the footer
underscore footer.css
so the next step now is to import these
partials to our main
sas file which is the style.css
so here i'm going to start with the
components and i'm going to write a
comment first
which is imports the components
so we have the use at rule
and then the components folder
and then you're going to start with the
animations
and then close it
then i'm going to duplicate three times
so we have the second component which is
the buttons and then the that one
which is the make sense and then
we have the third one which is the
typography
so let's do the same for the sections
comment first
so import
the sections
so again the use our tool
and then we have the sections folder
so we're going to start with the number
which is the first section of our
layouts
and then i'm going to close that and
then duplicate eight times
to total to nine so we have
one two three four five
six seven eight so the second section
we're going to import
the intro section we have the that
section which is the company's
the third one which is the services
we have the fifth fifth section which is
the testimonials
then we have the next section which is
so we have the frequently asked
questions
and then the next section which is
the portfolio
the next one is the get started
and finally we have the last one which
is
the footer
so i'm going to save that file
so now this file is going to import all
these partials with the code
and we are done with that part
welcome back in this video we are going
to start creating our project
and you're going to start with section
one of all out which is the navbar
so on the number we have a logo which is
also known as the nav brand
and then we have the menus and here we
have a button with a
phone number so let's get started and
create something similar like what we
have on the layout
so inside the project i'm going to
create a file called index.html
and then i'm going to add html starter
code
using emits so you're going to do a few
things on this
file the first one is to make sure that
you're using the correct viewports
and then you're going to add the title
and then link it with that style sheet
and also add the javascript
so let's start with the viewport and
we're going to check it from the
bootstrap documentation
so here on the introduction we have
something we call the
starter template it says be sure to have
your pages set up with the latest design
and development standards
that means using an html5 doctype and
including a viewport meta tag for proper
responsive behaviors
put it all together and the pages should
look like this
so here we're going to copy the viewport
meta tag
and then replace with what we have here
on the
file
so let's add the title and i'm going to
write learning bootstrap
version 5 with sas
then we need also now to link the style
sheet
so you have the link and then assets
folder
css and then style.css
then from there we're going to link the
javascript and here
from the documentation you have two
options the first option is by using the
bootstrap bundle
which has the popper and the second
option is by using them as separate
files that is the pop-up and the
bootstrap javascript
so here again you have the option to
either link them using the cdn
or downloading the source files i've
already downloaded the source files
and i have them in my project so we have
the assets and then we have this folder
called
js so i'm going to link that file using
the bootstrap bundle
dot js
so below the end of the body i'm going
to
add the scripts
so we have the source
so we have the assets folder
and then the js and then i'm going to
link it with the bootstrap bundle.js
so i'm going to save the file so the
starter template is ready we can go
ahead and create the navbar
so i'm going to start with a comment so
we have the start
the number section
so to save time i'm going to copy the
code from the bootstrap documentation
so here i'm going to go to components
and then down here we have the navbar
so here i'm going to scroll down till i
find the version that i want
so i'm going to copy the this code
and then i'm going to
paste so you can see now here
we have a class called container fluid
so in booster version 5
a container must be within the navbar
and you have the option to either use
the the container
fluid class or the container class so
i'm going to use the container class
so i'm going to save that and then
you're going to see
this page on our browser
so i'm going to go live and here we have
the navbar so we need to change the
color so i'm going to change from bg
light to bg primary
so there you have it so before we start
the number we need to do a few things on
it the first one is to add the logo
and then push these menus to the right
and then make sure that the menus
reflect what we have here
on the layout
so here we are going to start by pushing
the menus to the right
and here i'm going to add a class called
justify content
end so i'm going to add that class where
we have the collapse
class so we have that glass
and then you're going to add the logo
on the nav brand so you're going to use
an image
and here i'm going to create a folder
called images so you're going to keep
that logo inside that
folder so we have the images and then
the name of that logo which is
logo.png
and then we have the alt which is the
logo image
so let's create that folder so inside
the projects
[Music]
we have the images
then inside my project folder i'm going
to copy that
logo to my projects or to that folder
so i'm going to drag inside my project
folder
and then i'm going also to drag it to
that folder
so we can see the results so far on the
browser
and there you have it you can see the
logo and then the menus have been pushed
to the
right so we need to make sure that they
reflect what we have on the layout
so we have the home services
testimonials frequently asked question
portfolio contact
and then the button
so we have the second menu
which is the services
we have the that one
testimonials
so i'm going to duplicate the third one
three times so we have the frequently
asked question
we have portfolio
and then we have contacts
and then we have that button so i'm
going to
to remove this one the disabled link
so here we before we do that we're going
to add the
button at the end so we have the button
the type of the button is button
and then we have
the class for that button
so for now we're going to use rounded
peel to give it that rounded shape
we're going to add our own class
and then here going to add the telephone
number so we have the
plus 1 and then 0
2 8 3 6 5
4 1 3.
save let's see the result so far
so there you have it now we can start
styling so here we're going to do the
styling on the sas file for this section
which is the navbar.css so i'm going to
open that file
and then here i'm going to create a new
class which you're going to add to the
navbar
i'm going to call this class menu
so on the main we're going to create a
gradient background
so if you check here from the layout you
can see
here we have a gradient and these are
two colors we have the primary on the
left
that is our primary color and then on
the right we have that secondary color
or the secondary variable so let's
create that
gradient so we have the background
and then i'm going to use linear
gradient
so here we need to specify the direction
of the color so going to say
to write
and then we're going to use rgba
so we have our first color which is the
primary with an opacity of 0.95
then we need the second color again rgba
which is our secondary color
with an opacity of 0.95
i'm going to save the file make sure the
script is running and then add this
class to the navbar
so i'm going to remove the bg primary
and replace with that
menu class so i'm going to save
let's see the results on the browser
so what you're getting is an error for
undefined variable
and that is because the sas cannot be
able to get the modules with the
variables
so to use mixins or variables of these
modules we have to call them using
namespaces and by default the namespace
is the file name without the extension
so here on the navbar we need to call
that module which is the custom.css file
so this is the module which has all the
variables
mixins and the bootstrap so here we have
the
use at rule and then we need to go back
to directories so we have the two dots
and then
we have the custom so here we need to
use the namespace
and you have two options you can either
use it as custom
or just plain c so we're going to use it
as custom
and then close that and then i'm going
to save
let's see from the browser
so still you're getting an error so to
fix that we need to remove the namespace
so here we're not going to use it with
the namespace so we're going to use it
as a star so the star tells us to remove
the namespaces so i'm going to save
let's see and
there you have it you can see now it is
working
so let's continue styling so we need to
add the color
and do some padding on the menu items or
the nav items
so here you're going to nest it so we
have the li
we're going to do some padding
so for the top and bottom you're going
to put 0 and then
left and right 0.7 ram
save let's see and
there you have it you can see now we
have some padding on the nav items
so let's change the color to white so we
have the links
so we have the color so here we need to
put white
and then some text transform
to capitalize and then some
font to it you're going to have 600
so save let's see
so you can see the menus are bold but
the colors has not changed so here we're
going to fix that
with the important so we have the
important on the color
so i'm going to save and
there you have it so let's create a
mixing for this gradient because you're
going to use it
so many times so i'm going to open that
component which is
the mixing.css file
so here going to copy this gradient
so first let's create that mixing
so we have the gradient
mixing so that is a comment
so we have the at mixing
and the name of that mixing you're going
to call it gradient
so let's copy that background gradient
so i'm going to
cut actually cut and then here we're
going to include
it and then the name of that
mixing is gradient
so let's copy that gradient to the
mixing
so i'm going to save the two files
so our gradient should remain intact or
our number
so here we're getting an error for
undefined mixing so here
on the mixing we need to include that
module so
just like we did with the number we need
to include that module which is the
custom.css file
so it should be at the top so we're
going to
paste and then save let's see
so still you're getting an error for
undefined mixing this time
so we need to also include that module
on the navbar so the mixing components
so again we have the use at rule
and then we have
sorry we have
the components and then the mixins
so again use it as star
close save check on the browser
and there you have it so without mixing
now we can be able to reuse it
everywhere we want to use that gradient
so the next step now is to work on the
button and we need to create something
similar like what we have here on the
layout
so we're going to do that on the sas
file for that component which is the
buttons
dot scss so here i'm going to create a
new class
which is going to style that button and
i'm going to call it
btn rounded
so i'm going to start by setting the
position
to relative
and then some padding
for the top and bottom we're going to
set that to 0.9
ram and then left and right 1.25
ram then some font weight
i'm going to set that to 500
and then margin i'm going to set that to
zero
i'm going to save then add that class
to the button so we have the rounded
pill and then
btn rounded
so save let's see from the browser
and there you have it so we need to
remove this dark border
and replace that with the white border
and then
add this rounded circle which has this
icon
so here we're going to put that icon
inside a span so i'm going to create a
span
and then on the buttons
we are going to nest it the way we have
done so we have the span inside the bit
and rounded
span
so here i'm going to start by setting
the position to absolute
absolute and then background color of
that
rounded circle which is going to be
primary
then we need to set the width and the
height
of that rounded circle so we're going to
use
2.5 ram we can change that if it's too
large or too small and then also for the
height
2.5 ram
so then from there we're going to add
the module they've done here on the
navbar we need to include this
module so i'm going to copy
so remember here we have used this
variable so we need to
add it there and then save let's see
from the browser
so you can see now we have a span but
that is not the position that you want
it we want it inside the
button so let's first change the border
and then
give it that position
so for the border we are going to set
the border
so win the 0.1 ram solid
and then the color you're going to use
rgba
which you're going to set that to white
with an opacity of 0.6
then we need to position this span
so this one should be closed with a
semicolon
so for the top set that to 50 percent
write
5px
then we need to translate y that is
transform
translate y
minus 50 percent
so i'm going to save let's see
so you can see now at least we have it
on the position that you want but we
need to make sure that it's rounded and
then
do some padding on the btn rounded
so for the spawn you're going to set the
border radius
to 50
and then on the bottom
so this one should be 2.5 frame so
you're going to set
the padding for individual side so for
the top you're going to
leave it that to 0.9375
and then left
four points
ram and then for the bottom 0.9375 ram
the same with the top and then the other
one you're going to leave it at
1.25 ram so i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it that is our button
so now from there we're going to add the
phone icon and here we're going to use
the font awesome icons
so on html you're going to add that icon
inside the span
so we have the icon and then the class
font or some solid
and then the name of that icon is phone
alt
so here you're going to compile the font
or some sas file
so that you can be able to link that
style sheet
on the head section so inside the sss
folder i'm going to create that sas file
so i'm going to call it font awesome
dot scss
so here you're going to import four
files so we have the first one
so we have the user tool
and then the node modules font awesome
and then ss so you're going to start
with the brands
that is the phontosum for the brands
and then close duplicates
three times so the second second one
we're going to import the
regular and then we have the third one
which is the font awesome dot css
and then finally we have the solid
so i'm going to save and then here you
can see it has already compiled
our font awesome dot css so we need to
link that style sheet
to the head section so you have the link
and then assets
css and then fontosum.css
so from there now we're going to copy
the web fonts to the to our assets
folder
and the fonts can be found inside the
node
modules so we're going to copy them from
the
font awesome folder
so here we have that folder so i'm going
to copy it to the assets folder
so paste so now we'll be able to see
our icon so i'm going to the browser and
here you can see now we have that icon
so the next step is to style that icon
so inside the buttons
we're going to nest it inside the span
just like we have done on the html so we
have the icon
so the color should be white
so we have the white variable
and then also we need to position
at the center so here you're going just
to define
or specify the font size
or set the font size to one ram
and then also the line height
so you have the line height which you're
going to set that 2.5
frame so let's see save
and there you have it so you can see now
it is at the center of that
circle and that is the position that we
want it
so let's add the background color for
this
button to white so on the btn round
we are going to add that background
color
so we have white
save let's see and there you have it
so the next one now is to make sure that
we create the hoover effect
as you can see here from the layout so
once you hover you'll see that
gradients
so let's work on that
so here on the btn round we are going to
create that hoover so we have the hover
so the background color so here we're
going to call the
to use the mixing so we have to include
it
so include gradients
save let's see so we're getting
an error for undefined mixing so you
need to include that module inside
this file so just like we did with the
navbar
i'm going to copy that module copy
paste
and now you can see we have that hoover
with that gradient so we need to change
the color once you hover the
button and also this rounded circle
so on the hoover we need to set the
color to white
so we have color
which is white so i'm going to save
let's see from the browser
so now you can see once you hover the
button the color turns to white
so now let's work on this circle so we
need a dark circle once you hover there
but the button
so the span should be inside the hoover
so we have
the span and then the background color
so we are going to use rgba and they're
going to use a dark color
so we have the black with an opacity of
0.6
so i'm going to save let's see
so if you hover now you can see our
circuit turns to dark color
and that is exactly what we need
so if we check from the layout now you
can see the only thing we need to do is
bolden the text you can see ours
is a bit light so we need to add to
increase the font size the font weight
so on the b10 round you need to increase
the font weight to around 600
or let me have 700 save let's see
and there you have it
so i think we are done with our parts so
the next step now is to make sure that
our navbar is fully responsive across
variety of
screen devices and to do that i'm going
to right click and inspect elements
so this is how our navbar looks like on
moto g4
and this is a device with a screen
window of 360.
so we click here on the navbar toggler
you can be able to reveal the menu
so first let's change the color of this
navbar toggle to a light color
so here we have the class which you're
going to change from number light to
navbar
dark so
save let's see and
there you have it you can see now it
just changed to that light color
so something else is we can even hide
the button on small devices
and that is targeting devices with a
screen width of 600 and below or
575 and below so to do that you can
either write the media query on the
button where we have that
btn rounded
so bootstrap has some of the mixing that
you can use to create
a media queries so here we can include
that mixing
at the top and only hide that button on
small devices
with a screen window of 600 and below so
we have the include
that mixing so the mixing is media
breakpoint
down if you're targeting small devices
then you can write down
if you're targeting large devices then
you can say up
so down and then the
device we want to target is a small
device so you need to use the initials
which is
sm and then here we need to write
what you want to do so the properties
we're going to set the display to learn
so display none
so i'm going to save let's say from the
browser
so now if you click on the navbar
toggler you can't be able to see
the button on small devices
with a screen device or screen width of
600 and below
so to confirm that we need to open our
compile css
that is the style.css i'm going to open
to the side and see that media query
so here i'm going to search for that
class which is btn
rounded so
down here you can see that media query
it has already compiled so media query
marks win 575.98
px and you can see the display is set to
none
so you can see here any device with a
max window 575
the display should be set to none so it
will not be able to display that
button so let me show you if you're
targeting a large device
so here we can change the media player
breakpoint to media breakpoint up
so save let's see the media query and
here you can see the media query has
changed to minimum width
of 7 576. so if you check again from the
browser now
our button can be able to be seen on
small devices
but on large devices for example let's
go to a large device like an ipad pro
and you can see now we can be able to
see the button
so it depends on what you want to target
so again here we need to change that to
down because you only want
the button to be displayed on
large devices only so here targeting a
small device to display
none
so i think we are now our navba is fully
responsive
and everything is working perfectly fine
welcome back in this video we are going
to create section 2 of our layout
which is the intro section so here
you're going to start by creating this
intro heading and then on the right
you're going to create this illustration
and this animated button and also this
wavy background
so let's get started so on the html
let's create that section
so here i'm going to start with the
comments which is
start the intro
section so here we have that section
with an id of home and a class of
intro section
which will have a container
and the row and i'm going to create the
two columns so i'm going to group them
we have call md6
and another one called intros so here
i'm going to say times
2 to create the two columns so i'm going
to hit tab to create
them at once
so here i'm going to start with the
content for the first column and then
you're going to style it
later so from the left we have this
display
or heading and then we have description
and then the button
so for the heading you're going to use
h1 with a class of
display two display two is a bootstrap
heading class
and then you're going to start that
heading so you're going to use the span
with a class of display tool
and then you're going to modify that
with intro
so let me copy the text for the heading
or the display copy
and then paste and then i'm going to
duplicate
and then change that modifier to
description
so let me copy the text
paste
so let's create the button so here i'm
going to copy from the navbar
copy paste
and then change the content and the icon
so the content is get in touch
and then the name of that icon is arrow
right
so this is how our content looks like on
the browser so we need to do
some styling on that heading
in the description so on the typography
i'm going to open that
sas file so here we're going to use the
block element modifier to style the
heading
and the description so we have that
class called the display tool
and here going to set the margin bottom
to one rem and then text transform
i'm going to set that to capitalize
then you're going to modify the intro so
you have that
symbol or the app percent and then the
two dash
and then intro
so we're going to set the display to
inline block
and then font weights
i'm going to set that to 700.
so let's do the same also for
the description we have that and then
the two dashes
and then description
so if you noticed here on the intro i
didn't specify the font size so i wanted
to use the
display to font size that is available
in bootstrap
so for the description we're going to
set the font size to one ram
so we have the font size
one ram
and then here i'm going to set also the
display
to block
so i'm going to save and then
we need also to include the modules so
i'm going to copy them from the
buttons so i'm going to copy the
the first one
paste and then save so if you check now
from the browser this
is how our content looks like
so we need to style the intro section
so inside the sas file for that section
which is the intro section we're going
to
set the background
so first we need to include the two
modules
so we have the custom module
and the mixing so i'm going to copy the
two
and then paste
so we have that class intro section
so here we need that gradient so
we're going to include that mixing
so we have include
the name of that mixing is gradient
then we need to do some padding so i'm
going to use the shorthand and then only
specify the top
padding which is 10 ram for the rest i'm
going to
set that to 0 0 0
and then also we need to set the
width and the height so for the width
100 height
also 100
so i want the contents or the height to
scale with the content
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
and there you have it so we need to
separate the number and
the intersection so here we're going to
put the shadow
so we need some shadow on the navbar so
on the html
where we have the number i'm going to
include that class or to add that class
called shadow
and another class called fixed stop
save let's see so that is how it looks
like now so we need to change the colors
for the heading and the description
so on the typography we are going to set
the two colors
so we have the color
so we're going to use white save
let's see so here we need to include
or to add the margin top on the
description
so we have margin top
so i'm going to set that to 1.2 ram
so save let's see
so instead of using these colors here
so we're going to set them on the html
so i'm going to remove
and then set them on the html
so here on the row i'm going to add a
line item center
and then also add that class text white
and then i'm going to save let's see
so it's still in so the next step now is
to create the font style of this heading
if you check from the layout you can see
the font style is a bit different so
here we're going to use the font called
poppins
which you're going to get it from google
fonts so you can go to fonts.google.com
and here you're going to search for that
font called puppets so i'm going to type
poppins
and there it is i'm going to click on
that link
so here you need to select the styles
that you want to use
and i'm not going to use the italics so
i'm going to select and start with the
first one which is
the regular 400 so i'm going to select
it
so once you select them they'll be
displayed on this
viewer and then you need to select the
second one
which is the medium 500 i'm going to
select that style
we have semiball 600 select
we have the bold 700 i'm going to select
that style
we have the extra bold 800 select
and finally i'm going to select the
black 900
so the next step now is to copy the code
and paste it on the head section of all
layouts
so i'm going to copy
and then on the html where we have the
head section
so paste
and then from there let's go back to the
google fonts and then you need to copy
the rules so i'm going to copy that
rule css rules to specify formulas
and then on the typography
we're going to paste it where we want to
use that font family
so we are going to paste on the display
tool and then on the intro
and then i'm going to save the two files
check on the browser and
there you have it so let's increase the
font size
of the description and also
set the text transform to none on the
description
so here we need to increase the font
size to 1.5
and then set the text transform
to none i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it so for the text
for the description we need to add
a class for line height
so here i'm going to add that class so
we have lh
base i'm going to use lhbs or
lh
large
so let's see how la the large looks like
so i'm going to save check on the
browser
so line height lag is a bit large so
let's use
line height base so i'm going to save
so i think line height base is a bit
better
so i think we are done with that part so
the next step now is to create
the second column from the layout here
you can see we have this illustration
and this animated play button and once
you click
the animated button a video will pop up
from youtube or any other source that
you choose
so let's work on that
so i will start by copying this
illustration to my project
and here i have that illustration it's a
png so i'm going to copy
to my project so inside the images
folder i'm going to create another
folder called
at
so this way i'm going to keep all the
illustrations
and then paste
so you can also get this illustration on
this website called
manypixels.co
slash gallery so here you can search for
that illustration you can also filter by
categories types
and also change the color so first let's
change the color
so here i'm going to use our one of the
variables color
and i'm going to use the purple light so
i'm going to copy the x value
copy and then here we need to change
that value
paste so before you search
first make sure that you change the
color and then here we're going to
search for that illustration
and just type coding
so if you type that you'll be able to
see that illustration and there it is
so i'm going to click it so that i can
be able to download you can either
download it as a
svg or a png so either way we'll work
so once you do that then we can create
that
column or that content so inside the
html
so first you're going to start with the
comment so we have this second column
and i'm going to stay start
the content for the video
and then also for the first column
start the content
for the intro
so here going to create a class called
videobox
which is going to keep all everything
so we have videobox
and then we have that image
so we have the images folder
and then ads and then
intro section illustration.png
and then we have the video illustration
so we need also to add that glass for
responsive images
it's called image fluid
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
and there you have it you can see now
you have that illustration so let's push
it to the
right or to the end so here we're going
to add a class called
on the intros where you have that column
you're going to add the text end class
to push it to the end i'm going to save
let's see and there you have it now you
can see
it's on the edge or the end so next
let's add the play button
so we're going to add the play button
after the illustration
and it will be inside the link so you
have the link
and then also inside the span
so we have the icon and here we're going
to use phonto some icons
so we have the icon and then the class
font or some solid
and then the name of that icon is play
circle
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
so you can see this small icon here so
we're going to style it
so inside the intro section we're going
to do the styling of that file
and you're going to nest it the way
we've done here on the html so we have
the container for the content which is
the intros
and then we have the video box inside
the intros we have the link
inside the video box and then we have
this pan inside the link and the icon
inside the span so that's how you're
going to do the nesting
so on the intersection we're going to
create that class
so we have the intros as the container
for the content
and then we have the video box inside
the intros
and then we have the link inside the
video box
and then we have the span inside the
link and then we have the icon
inside the span
so for the video box we are going to set
the position to relative
and then on the link you're going to set
the position
to absolute
and then here we're going to set the
font size on the
icon and i'm going to use six ram
you can change that later it's too small
or too large and then
the color i'm going to use a dark color
but you're going to change it later so
here we're going to use black
so i'm going to save let's see there is
also found the browser
and there you have it you can see now we
have that icon and that is not the
position that you want
to be so we need it at the center of the
column or that the
illustration so here we can use the
bootstrap utilities
for positioning that icon and
in earlier version of bootstrap we only
had a position static
position relative position absolute
position fixed position sticky
in the new version now you can arrange
your elements using these properties
like the top
for the vertical top position we have
the stat for the horizontal left
position in left to right
we have the bottom for the vertical
bottom position
we have the end for the horizontal right
position in left to right
you can also just use these other values
for the zero
for zero edge position fifty for the
fifty percentage position
hundred four hundred percent edge
position so you can see we have those
properties here or the classes you can
also
center your elements using these new
classes
we have the translate middle and then
you also have
this applies to transformation translate
x for the minus fifty percent and
translate way for the minus
50 to the element which in combination
with the edge positioning utilities
allows you to absolute center and
elements
so you're going to be using some of
these classes
to position that icon but for now we
need
to write our own and here we're going to
write it or create
a mixing which are going to reuse this
code
so inside the makesense.css you're going
to create that mixer
so here is i'm going to start with the
comment which is
absolutes
center
so we have the at mixing
and i'm going to call it absolute
center
so here going to set the position to
absolute
and then top 50
50 percent left also 50
transform
translate
we have minus 50 percent
and then minus 50 percent
i'm going to save and then you're going
to include this mixing
on the link
so i'm going to include that mixing
absolute center so we have it here
close and then i'm going to save so
let's see from the browser
and there you have it you can see now we
have our icon at the center of that
column so if you check from the layouts
you can see now that is the position
that our icon should be
so let's change the color to reflect
what we have on the layout so here we
are going to use
secondary
save sorry we have the secondary
save
and there you have it you can see now we
have that icon at the position that
you want it so this mixing you can reuse
it
every time that you want to position
something at the center that is position
absolute
so now let's use the bootstrap position
utilities to position
the icon so we're going to do it on the
html
so here on the link you're going to add
the class
and we're going to start with position
absolute that is the class
and then top 50.
and then start 50.
and then you need center to center the
elements or the icon
and you're going to use translate middle
so we have it here i'm going to save and
then where we have that
position absolute you're going to remove
it or just comment it
so i'm going to save so let's see from
the browser
and as you can see our icon is still
intact at the position that
it was previously so next up we are
going to create the background wave
so from the layout here you can see we
have this background wave at the bottom
of that
section so you're going to do this from
the help of
this website called getwaves.io
so here you're going to make sure that
we generate something close or something
similar
like what we have here on the layouts
so you can use these two buttons to
change the direction of the
wave we have the one facing at the top
and the one facing at the bottom
here you can change the color and here
you can play around with this button to
generate random waves till you find the
one
that you want to use so we're going to
change the direction facing the app
and then i'm going to do play around
with this but until i find the one close
or similar to the one we have used here
on the layout
so i'm going to use this one i'm going
to click to get the code
so copy svg code
and then on the html at the bottom of
that section
i'm going to paste
and then i'm going to change this color
from blue to white
so hex value for white is fff
or 6f and then i'm going to save
check on the browser
and there you have it now we have that
background wave
so the next step now is to animate this
icon from the layout
you can see the play button is animated
so let's work on that
so on the intro section we're going to
create a class called
border animation
so here you're going to set the position
to obsolete
obsolete
and then you're going to set the width
and the height and you're going to use
the same size we used
on the fonts on that icon sorry which is
six ram
so we have the width
we have 6 ram same with height
6 ram
then we need the border
we're going to start with the width
which i'm going to set to 0.55
frame solid
color i'm going to use white
so i'm going to save and then you're
going to add this class
to the html where we want that
border to be so
i'm going to create a span with a class
of border animation class
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
so you can see this border
so let me change the color to be able to
see it properly
so i'm going to change from white to
black
save let's see
so you can see this border so we need to
change the color
sorry we need to make it round so we
need to change the border radius or set
the border radius to
50 percent
so we have border radius
50
save let's see
and there you have it so the next thing
now is to position it to where we have
this icon
because it must be in that position same
position with the icon
so that can be able to animate position
that you're going to set
the top position to zero and also the
left position to zero
so we have left
zero so i'm going to save
let's see from the browser
and there you have it now it is at the
position where we have that icon
so next i'm going to create an animation
which is going to animate
that border so inside the animations.css
we're going to create an animation
called pulse so i'm going to start with
the comment which is
pulse border
so here we have the keyframes
and i'm going to call it pulse
border
so from zero percent we are going to
scale it
from one so we have
transform and then scale it one
scale it one
and then two hundred percent we're going
to scale it to 1.5
so we have
scale 1.5
then you're going to add this animation
to our animation border class
so animation name
we have that pulse border
it's going to last for one second linear
infinite
so you have linear infinite
so i'm going to save let's see
from the browser so you can see now
animation is already working
so we're going to create two animations
so here on the html we're going to
duplicate
and then here going to modify that
animation
so we have the first border minus minus
border one
so here you're going to set the two
borders with a different animation delay
so we have animation delay for the first
border
which is going to last for one second
and then for the second border
minus minus border two
animation delay
so you have this animation delay 1.2
seconds
so even this one should be animation
delay not animation
animation delay
so i'm going to save then on the html we
need to nest it there we have done
so here we're going to add for the first
one we have
border animation minus minus
border one
so i'm going to copy that to the second
border
so this one should be border two so i'm
going to save let's see from the browser
so we can't be able to see the border so
what you're going to do here on the
animation you're going to set the
opacity
for the first from zero
we're going to set the opacity to one
and then on the hundred percent we're
going to set
opacity to zero so you have opacity
one
i'm going to copy
and then this one will be 0 200
so i'm going to save let's see
so now you can see we have the two
borders so we need to change the delay
animation delay so here on the intro
section we need to change
from 1.2 to 1.5
and then also this one should last for
1.5
so i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it you can see now
the two borders so let's change the
color
to white on the border
save let's see
and now as you can see that is our
animation
so if you check from the layout
you can see we have achieved the same
results
and i think we are done with that part
so the next thing is to create the video
pop-up you can see from the layout
once you click this animated play button
a video will pop up from youtube or any
other source that you choose
it can even be a self-hosted video
so to create that you're going to use a
free javascript lightbox called
g lightbox from brt digital
so you can go to github and search for
this brt digital or just
g lightbox alternatively you can also go
to
npmjs and search for that package called
g lightbox
so here you see it says deletebox is a
pure javascript lightbox
it can display images iframes inline
contents and videos with optional
autoplay for youtube
vimeo and even self hosted videos so you
can see it has some good features
it's fast and responsive that means it
can work with any screen
size we have the gallery support you can
create multiple galleries
we have video support for youtube vimeo
and self-hosted videos with autoplay
we have support for inline content
iframe support keyboard navigation
touch navigation zoomable images api
that means you can control the light box
with the provided methods
and also it's dimmable that means you
can create your skin or modify the
animation
with some minor css changes then on the
usage we have different ways of using
this
lightbox you can install it using npm
and you can also
manually download the source files and
then link the javascript in your html
so i'm going to go with the second
option that is to download the source
files and then i'm going to link the
javascript
and the style sheet in my html i have
downloaded the source files so i'm just
going to copy the source files to my
projects
so here we have this folder called g
lightbox master and this is the folder
which has all the source files
so inside that folder we have another
folder called list
and this is the folder which has the
files that you're going to use
so if you open that file you'll see we
have the css folder
which has the style sheet and we have
the two versions
and then also we have the js folder
which has the javascript and again we
have the two versions
so i'm just going to copy the two
folders to my projects
so copy and then inside my projects
so i'm going to keep them inside the
assets folder
and then inside their search folder i'm
going to create another folder
and i'm going to call it vendors so here
i'm going to keep all the
source files for vendors so we have
vendors
then inside that folder i'm going to
paste
so then from there now we're going to
link the two files
to the on the html so let's start with
the javascripts
and they're going to link link it at the
bottom
so here we have the scripts
and then we have the source
so we have the assets folder
and then vendors and then js
so you can use any of the two options
i'm going to use the minified version
and then we need also to link the style
sheets
on the head section
so we have link and then we have the
assets folder
vendor and then css
and again i'm going to use the minified
version
then from there we're going to set the
lightbox options for the video
you can see here we have the light box
options and we have the options for the
image
and you can see the type is an image and
then we have the options for the video
and you can see the type is a video so
here we have the link
which is an option you need to set the
link
and then you have the type whether it's
an image or video and then the source
here you need to specify the source
either from youtube female or
self-hosted video
and then we have the width you can also
set the autoplay videos to true
first you need to declare using the
const keyword so i'm going to copy
that declaration
and then at the bottom we need to create
another script
immediately below the lightbox
javascript
so we have the script and the type
is text
javascript
and then i'm going to paste so here you
need to remove the
touch navigation loop and the auto play
videos
and then you're going to replace that
with the options that we have
for the video so i'm going to copy
just to save time
and then we need to replace
the link for the video
so here i'm going to copy from one of my
videos i have on youtube
so you have two options you can either
copy the url of the video
or just click on this link that says
here
then you can copy the link
so i'm going to replace that
and then paste and then from there we
need to add
the g lightbox class where we have that
animated play button
so we have g lightbox
so you need to add that class and then
i'm going to save
so let's see from the browser
so now if you click the animated play
button you'll be able to see
the pop-up from youtube
so you can see now we have that pop-up
from youtube so here remember you can
also set
the auto play videos to true
so you need to add that option so we
have auto play
videos
we have true and then i'm going to save
let's see again
so now if you click again you'll be able
to see the autoplay videos working
and there you have it so in this video
we're going to build a mod
and the good thing about that lightbox
you can see it's fully responsive and
this one is a screen
device with a screen window 316 you can
see
it's fully responsive so i'm going to
switch to another device like a medium
device
and again you can see our our light box
or the pop-up is fully responsive
so with that we are
so with that we are done with that part
so the next thing nice to make sure that
our section is fully responsive across
variety of screen devices
and to do that i'm going to right click
and inspect elements
so before you write any media query or
do anything we're going to see how our
sections look like
on various devices so this one is moto
g4
it's a device with a screen window of
360.
and the content is not bad so here we
can decrease the font size a bit for the
description
so let's see from another device like
pixel 2. here the content is not that
bad
what about iphone x
not good ipad
not good
so what about surface duo
not bad
iphone 678 plus
i think not bad but here we can
decrease the font size of the
description a bit
so to make this work we are going to
[Music]
on the typography where we have the
description we are going to decrease the
font size for small devices
that is any device with the screen width
of 600 and below
we're going to set the font size or
decrease the font size
so here we're going to focus first on
mobile devices so we're going to set the
font size to
one ram and then here i'm going to write
a media query which is going to target
large devices so we have
that mixing so include media breakpoint
up so from large
so you have to use those initials lg for
large devices
and then we are going to set the font
size
to 1.5 frame
also we're going to set the
display to inline block
so here the display
we're going to set that to inline block
so i'm going to save and look at the
content again
so now you can see on this device which
is an iphone 6 plus
the description is a bit small and that
is what i wanted
so let's see from another device like
moto g4
still the same so what about an ipad
as you can see the section is
good on that device
so let's see from an ipad pro
and there you can see now the font size
of that description is a bit big
so it can even decrease to 1.4 m so let
me decrease to 1.4
save let's see
yeah now you can see the content is not
bad perfect
so let me go back to moto g4
perfect
pixel 2 perfect
surface duo perfect
iphone 5s e i think
we need to target i think it's all bad
so with that i think our section is
fully
responsive and we can move on
welcome back in this video we are going
to create section 3 of
our layout which is the companies so
let's get started and create something
similar like what we have here on the
layout
so on the html we're going to start that
section
so i'm going to start with a comment
start
the companies
so here we have that section with a
class with an id of
companies and a class of
companies
it will have a container
and a row
so here we're going to start with that
heading we have trusted by companies
like
so i'm going to copy
so here we have h4 with a class of
font-weight bold and a glass of lead
and some margin so i'm going to use mp3
margin bottom three
and then the text
tab and there you have it so i'm going
to save
so let's see from the browser result so
far
so this is our text so we need it at the
center so i'm going to add
on the row text center class
so we have the text center
save let's see
and there you have it you can see we
have our text at the center
next i'm going to add the heading line
from the layout here you can see we have
a line below the heading or the display
and actually these are two lines so we
have the first line which is content
before
and the second line which is content
after so let's work on that
so on typography i'm going to add that
class first i'm going to start with a
comment which is
heading line
the class i'm going to call it heading
line so this one is for the first line
so we have content before
and then we have the contents
and then i'm going to set the width
for the first line to 10 ram
and then the height i'm going to set
that to
0.1 ram
then i'm going to set the display
to block
then some background color
i'm going to use primary
and then i'm going to duplicate this
class for the content after
so duplicate and then here we need after
so this one is for the second line or
the line below the first line
so i'm going to save and then you're
going to add that class
below the heading
and then i'm going to save let's see
from the browser
so we have the lines let me add some
margins so that you can be able to see
it properly so we have
margin bottom five
save let's see so now you can see we
have our first line
so because they are having the same
width so i'm going to change for the
second
which i'm going to set to to ram
and then for the width height i'm going
to set that to 0.2
save let's see
and now you can see we have the line the
first one and the second one
so here we need to set some margin
so for the second line i'm going to set
some padding at the top
so we have padding top i'm going to use
0.5
ram and then i'm going to save
let's see so now you can see we have the
two lines
the second one is a bit has a higher
height than the
first one so we need them at the center
so here we're going to add
so i'm going to select the two and then
add the margin
that is set the margin to zero outer
for horizontal centering
and then i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it now you can see we
have our line at the center
so for the second line i'm going to add
some margin at the bottom
margin bottom to one rem
save let's see
and there you have it next i'm going to
add
the images or these logos to my project
so we have the six
logos so here i have a folder called
companies you can see
the logos are named company one all the
way to company six so i'm going to copy
the entire folder to my project
so copy
so i'm going to copy them inside the
images folder
so on the html you're going to create
that content and i'm going to create
another container so here we're going to
start with a comment which is start
the company's
content
so we have a container class
which will have a row
and then i'm going to create the six
columns which will have the
logos so here i'm going to group them
so i'm going to use call md4
and then another class or another
container for the logos
i'm going to call it companies then i'm
going to use
block element modifier to style that
logos so we have the companies and then
underscore underscore
logo box
then we need the images so we have the
image
and then the source of the images we
have
the images folder
and then the companies folder which have
the logos
so if you check here again from the
folder you'll see the company
logos are named company one all the way
to company six and they are in png
so here we have to write that
company minus dollar sign to assign each
value
and then dot png
then we need an alt which will be
company dollar sign logo
then we need the title
so the title will be company again
dollar sign logo
then we need a class called image fluid
for responsive images
so we have image fluid
so here i'm going to say time 6 to
generate the six columns with the
content at once
hit tab and there you have it you can
see now we have
the six columns with the contents
so let me arrange them properly here
and then i'm going to save let's see
from the browser
so now we have our logos the next step
now is to style them
so inside the companies.css file that is
the sas file for that section so i'm
going to open that and you're going to
start by styling
this class called companies because this
is the container for the content
on that section
so we have the class
companies so here i'm going to start by
setting the padding
sorry not padding top but padding you're
going to use the shorthand
for the top zero and then
zero and then for the bottom you're
going to set that to five frame
and then zero for the left
and then here we have the companies
sorry
we have this class remember how we have
nested them we have the companies and
then underscore underscore logo box
so that's how you're going to nest it so
we have
my underscore underscore logo box
because the logo box is the parent
container of all the logos
that is the images you can see here we
have the logo box and then the images
so here going to set the width so we
have we are going to use max width
we're going to set that 200 percent
then we're going to set the height
so here i'm going to use three ram you
can change that
then you're going to style the image
so here again only to set the height so
that it can scale to 3 ram so i'm going
to set the height 200 percents
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
and there you have it you can see now we
have the images of scaled
to the window of the column and the
height of that
which is rhythm so
let's continue styling here so here i'm
going to add some margin
at the bottom
i'm going to use two ram and then we
need some padding
i'm going to use 0.5 ram
and then we have text align
center and then not forgetting you to
set the position to relative
i'm going to save let's say from the
browser
and there you have it now you can see
they have scaled so we need to add some
shadow on the columns
you can see from the layout here we need
some shadow
so on the html i'm going to select all
the classes
the logo box
and then i'm going to add the shadow
small so we have that glass
shadow small
so i'm going to save let's see
and now as you can see we have the
shadow
so the next step knows to make sure that
our section is fully responsive across
variety of screen devices
so i'm going to right click and inspect
elements
so you can see this one is moto g4 a
screen window of 360 and
the logos are screen scaling and fitting
nicely in one column
so i'm going to check it from another
device like an ipad
and you can see these are an ipad a
screen window of 768
and they're fitting nicely in three
columns
so i'm going to check it from another
device larger than that
so we have ipad pro and you can see
also they are fitting nicely but here we
have so much space that they can fit in
one
line so to fix that i'm going to
add another color for target large
devices so i'm going to select all the
columns
or the classes
and then i'm going to add that class or
that column that is called
lg2 so i'm going to save
save let's see
so now they are fitting in one line so
i'm going to
change their screen width
and here you can see again they're
fitting in nicely in
one line so i'm going to close the
inspector
and as you can see we have the logos
fitting nicely in one
line as we what we have here on the
layout
so the next thing is to make sure that
once you hover the logos they turn to
grayscale
so let's create that hover effect so on
the companies where we have
the image
we have the hoover
so we have the filter
property and then grayscale so i'm going
to set that to 120
save let's see so now if you try to
hover the
logos you see they're turning to
grayscale
so i think we're done with that part we
can move on to the next step
welcome back in this video we are going
to create section 4 of the layout
which is the services or our services so
let's get started and make sure that we
create something similar like what you
have here on the layout
so on the html i'm going to start that
section
first i'm going to start with a comment
which is start
section 4.
the services
so we have the section with an id of
services and a class of
our services
which will have the container
and the row so i'm going to hit tab
so we are going to start with that
heading so we have the
our services and then this heading line
copy so this one is h1
with a class of display 3
and a class of font-weight bold
so i'm going to tab i'm going to save
then we need that heading line so we
have the class
heading line and some margin at the
bottom
so mb5 so i'm going to save let's see
so we have the heading so we need it at
the center so here we're going to add
the
text center class so we have the text
center i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it
so next we are going to create the font
style of this heading so
we're going to do the same way we did
with display 2 on the introduction
so we're going to add that font family
called poppins
so on typography we're going to create
that
display 3. so first is a comment which
is
display three
and then you have that class display
three
so here i'm going to copy the font
family from display too
so copy and then you're going to paste
save let's see
and there you have it you can see now
the heading
is using that font family called poppins
next we are going to create the two
columns which have the two description
and the border at the center so let's
work on that
so here i'm going to create another
container
for that content
so i'm going to start with a comment
which is start
the description content
so you have a container class
[Music]
which will have a row and the row will
have
some padding at the top so i'm going to
use padding top
three sorry two and some padding at the
bottom
so we have padding bottom two
and then some margin at the top five
and then some margin at the bottom so m
b
three and then we need the two columns
so i'm going to
group them so i'm going to use
call md6
and then i'm going to say times two to
create the two at once hit tab
so i'm going to start with the
description for the first column
so here we have a class called bg white
and some padding so i'm going to use p3
tab and then h2
with a class of font-weight bold
and a class of text capitalize
and the class of text center
so i'm going to copy the text from the
layouts
copy paste
then for the second column the
description for the second column
again we have bg
white and a class of
some padding so we're going to use b4
and then a class of text
stats to align it at the left
then you're going to create a paragraph
with a class of font-weight lights
and a class of
text stats but you already have it on
the bg head so i'm going to
hit tab and then i'm going to copy that
text from the layout
paste
i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
so there we have now our two description
so the next thing now is to add this
border at the center
of the two columns so here i'm going to
create a class called boulder right
so in the first column i'm going to add
that class which you're going to style
it
we have border right
and then inside the typography we're
going to style it
let's start with the comment which is
border right
and then the class is buddha rights
so we have that property boda right and
i'm going to set
the width to 0.1 ram
solid and i'm going to use
gray 300.
and then here i'm going to set the
height to 100
so we have the height 100 percent
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
and there you have it you can see now we
have that border at the center of the
two
description next i'm going to create the
three content for the services
so from the layout here we have
marketing web development
and cloud hosting so for each service we
have an icon
heading text button and then an
illustration same way with the second
and the third one so let's work on that
so here i'm going to start another
container for that content
so first you're going to start with the
comment which is start
the content
for the services
so here you're going to generate the
three sections at once
using emits so you can see here from the
layout you have the two sections we have
the first
section which are the content and then
on the right we have an illustration
same way with the second and the dad
so here we have a container
and then we have a row so i'm going to
group it
the row will have two columns each so
i'm going again to group them
so we have for large devices you're
going to use
call lg6 and then for medium devices
we're going to use
call md6
and then for small devices you're going
to use call
small 12 and then
for extra small you're going to use
call extra small 12
and then we needed another container for
the content
so i'm going to call it services
then we need margin at the top so i'm
going to use margin top 4
then from there we need now the
container for the content that is the
text
so we have i'm going to call it services
here we're going to use block element
modifier underscore underscore
contents so for the columns i'm going to
say times two
so that we have two columns for each row
and then you're going to create the
three rows
or the three sections so i'm going to
say times three
so that means for each row we'll have
two columns each
so i'm going to hit tab and then it's
going to generate for us all the three
sections
so you can see now we have the first row
having the two columns
the second row having the two columns
for web development
and then the that row or the that
section having the two columns for cloud
hosting
so i'm going to comment them so that we
can know where they start
so we have start
the marketing content
tab so we have the second one
so start the web development content
and then finally the that one which is
start
the cloud hosting
content
so i'm going to start with the content
for marketing and we have that content
on the first column
so here i'm going to add the content and
then i'm going to style it later
so we have the icon and then the heading
and then the text and then this button
and then on the second column we have
this illustration
so let's work on that so here i'm going
to create a class called icon which is
going to style
that icon and then you're going to add
that icon
so we have the font or some solid class
and then the name of that icon
is paper plane
tab then the second item is the heading
so we have h3 with a class of display
three
so here i'm going to use block element
modifier to style it so we have display
three
and and then minus minus title
then i'm going to add some margin at the
top so we have margin top one
tab and then the heading is marketing
that item is the text so we are going to
have a paragraph with a class of line
height
large
so here going to add some dummy text so
we have lorem
28
then you we have the button so here
you're going to copy
the button from the intro section
so i'm going to scroll up and then copy
the button
so we have and then here i'm going to
change
the text to learn more
so i'm going to save let's see how it
looks like on the browser so far
so this is our content so here going to
add the border primary
to the button so i'm going to add that
class
so we have border primary
save let's see and there you have it
so now we can go ahead and copy this
content to the rest of the two sections
so i'm going to copy the icon the
heading the paragraph
and the button
so for the second column which is web
development we have that content on the
second
column so i'm going to paste it on the
second column
and then for cloud hosting we have that
content on the first column
paste then i'm going to change the
heading to cloud hosting
and then also change the icon so that
icon is called
cloud
upload alt
and then we have web development
and also going to change the icon to
code
so i'm going to save
so let's see from the browser and these
are our content looks like
so we have marketing that is the content
for marketing
web development and cloud hosting
next i'm going to add the illustrations
and they already have them
so i have a folder called services which
has the three illustrations in png
so i'm just going to copy the entire
folder to my project
so inside the services i'm going to
paste
so now we can go ahead now and add the
illustrations so let's start with the
marketing
so for the first row we have the
illustration on the second column
so here we have an image with a class of
image fluid
and then we have an alt
we have marketing
illustration
tab so we have the
images folder which is the source
and then the services and then service
one dot png
that is for marketing so i'm just going
to copy this
to web development so that we have the
illustration on the first column
paste and then you're going to change
the value to service to
and then change also the alt to web
development
i'll do the same to the third one which
is cloud hosting so we have it on the
second
column
paste change the value to service 3
and also the alt which is cloud hosting
illustration so i'm going to save let's
see from the browser
and there you have it now we have the
three illustrations
so the next step now is to style the
content and you're going to do that on
the sas file for that section which is
the services.css
so here i'm going to start with the
container for the content which is the
services class
and then we need to do some correction
on the html so at the beginning of that
section
we created a class called our services
so let's rename that to just
services
and then save so
on this container we're going to set to
start by setting the
position to relative
and then some padding
i'm going to use the shorthand top and
bottom you're going to use one ram
and then for left and right zero
and then you're going to nested the web
done on the html
so we have this class called services
underscore underscore content
and then we have the icon inside the
content
so that's how we're going to nest it so
we have
underscore underscore content inside the
services
so here again we're going to save the
padding for the contents
to one ram all sides
then some margin at the top
i'm going to use 1.5 ram
and then we need to style the icon so we
have that icon class inside the content
so for the font size we're going to set
that to
2.5 ram you can change that letter if
it's too
big or too small and then the color
we have primary
so i'm going to save and then we need to
use the module
at the top so we have the use at rule
and then custom so use it as
star
save let's see from the browser result
so far
and there you have it so we have our
icon
with a font size of five 2.5
next we're going to style the heading so
if you check here from the layout you
can see
the heading is as if it says two colors
so we have some
purple at the left and then on the right
we have this pinkish color
so here we're going to use background
clipping
so on typography we are going to style
it the way we have done the html again
so you can see we have display three so
we're going to modify that
display three so if you check again from
the html here
just to show you where we have the
heading
we have displayed three class and then
minus minus title
so you're going to modify it that we
have done there
so we have minus minus title
so here i'm going to start with the font
size
i'm going to set that to 1.8 ram
then text transform
we're going to set that to capitalize
and then font wait
i'm going to use 600
and then the font family so again to
copy what we have here
and then set the display to inline block
so we have that background clip
we're going to clip text
so before we set the background clip we
need to the background color
so we have the background image
we're going to use linear gradient
because we need the two colors
so the direction of the color is two
right
and then we have the first color primary
second color secondary
then we need to clip the text so here
you're going to use a property called
webkit text field color so we have
webkit
text field color and you're going to use
transparent
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
so here we need to set
for the webkit
background clip check on the browser
and there you have it you can see now it
has clipped that background color
so here we need to set the display on
the html
to block so that they can be on separate
lines
so the html where we have the icon
you're going to set the display to block
so i'm going to select the three
icon classes
and then display block
save let's see and there you have it
so something else on the html we need to
put to push
the illustrations on the edge
so we're going to select the second
sorry the first one which is the
marketing so we have that illustration
we're going to add that class called
text end where we have the column
so we have the text end
to push it to the edge
and then for the web development you're
going to also do the same
on the illustration where we have that
class sorry the column
so we have the text stats
and then also
for the cloud hosting we have that
illustration so we're going to set that
to text end
save let's see
so now you can see the illustration have
been pushed to the start
and the end
so something else is we need to do some
correction on where we have the
illustration
so on the html let's start with the
marketing
so here we have that class called
services underscore underscore content
we need to change that to
pick so that it represents the
the illustration so let's do the same
also for the second
that is web development we're going to
replace that with services underscore
underscopic
for picture and also the that one which
is the
cloud hosting i'm going to change that
to
pic
then on the sass file we need to
nest it that way we have done
so we have
underscore underscore peak so here
you're going to set the max width
to 100
and then for the content we need to
change the margin top to five ram
so i'm going to save let's say from the
browser
so that is how our content looks like
much better now
next you're going to make sure that our
section is fully responsive
so i'm going to right click and inspect
elements
so this is how the section look like on
moto g4
that's our device with a screen window
of 360.
so you can see we have so much or big
spaces between the contents
so for the first one which is the space
between the heading and the first
description
and this has to do with margin so let's
go to the html
so where we have the heading line you're
going to change the margin bottom
from mb5 to mb 1
and then save let's see
so you can see now the space has reduced
a bit
again also here we have the margin top
where we have the first description
let's change the margin top to zero
save let's see so you can see now the
space
is much better the next one is the space
between the second description and
marketing so this is the content for
the services so let's see from the html
so again here you can see we have so
many containers we have a container for
the heading
we have another container for the two
description and another container for
the services so let's remove the
container where we have the
description so so that they can share
the container
with the heading so let's remove
this one and also this container
so i'm going to save let's see
so now the content is running nicely
so the next one is the space between
you can see here we have this space but
still
so here we're going to write a media
breakpoint which is going to target
large devices
so on the sas file
where we have the content we have margin
top so here i'm going to create a media
breakpoint which is going to target
large devices we have that mixing
include
media breakpoint
up
so that is from large devices
large so here i'm going to copy the
margin top
so we're going to set that to 5 ram
and then the default you're going to set
that to zero
so i'm going to save let's see so you
can see that one has already fixed that
the next one is to work on the icon and
the heading
again here going to write another media
breakpoint
where we have the icon and the font size
on typography so i'm going to copy this
media breakpoint
and use it where we have the icon
so here on large devices you're going to
set that to
2.5 and then the default you're going to
set that to 1.5
again on typography let's go to
typography i have display three
so let's copy that video breakpoint
copy
so here we're going to set the font size
to 1.5 1.8
1.8
and then for other devices it's going to
remain to
0 to 1 ram and then i'm going to save
let's see now
so you can see that has already fixed
that you can see the
the icon and the heading they're a bit
small now
on small devices so i'm going to change
another device
larger than that let's see from an ipad
also you can see the font size of the
heading
and the icon a bit small now so you can
even reduce the font size of the text
yeah let's do that so on the services
inside the contents
we have the paragraph that is the p
font size
so the default you're going to set that
to 0.8 ram
and then you're going to write another
media breakpoint
so here we are going to set that to one
ram
one ram
that will target only the large devices
so i'm going to save let's see
so you can see now much much better
i think we can increase the font size of
the heading
so let's set that to 1.1 or 1.2
save let's see so i think now everything
is much better
so let's change to another device ipad
pro that's a large device
so you can see the contents is nicely
fitting
moto g4 again you can see
the content is nicely fitting on that
screen device so that means our
section is fully fully responsive
and you can move on to the next section
welcome back in this video we are going
to create section 5
of the layout which is the testimonials
so here we are going to use bootstrap
component called carousel
so let's get started and create
something similar like what you have on
the layout
so on the html we are going to start
that section
so first we are going to write a comment
which is start
start section 5
the testimonials
so here we're going to start that
section with an idea of
testimonials
and a class of testimonials
so which will have a container
and a row tab
so here going to start with the heading
so we have this heading and then
this line and then the subheading
so copy so this one is h3
with a class of display 33
actually h1 sorry with a class of
display 3
and then with a class of font-weight
bold
so we have the text tab
then we have that line so we have
h hr
so we're going to style it so we have
style
width we're going to set that to
100px and then we have the height
repeat x
so and then we have the class
so this one should be we have the class
mx auto for horizontal centering
so i'm going to save so let's see
our text
so we have our text we need to align it
at the center
so on the row we are going to add the
text center class
save so now we have the text at the
center
i'm going also to add the subtitle so we
have this
subtitle below the heading that says
what our clients are saying
so we have a paragraph with a class of
lid and some padding at the top
so we're going to use padding top one
and then we have that text
what our clients
are saying
so i'm going to save let's see
so now we have that text
next i'm going to style this section so
on the sass file for that section i'm
going to open that file
which is the testimonials.css so here
i'm going to start by
using the two modules so we have the use
at rule
and then we have custom use it as
star
so i'm also going to include or to use
the mixing
so we have the use
and then components
and then mixing dot css again
use it as star
so here i'm going to add that class
which is testimonials
so i'm going to start by setting the
position to relative
then we have padding i'm going to set
that to zero
and then we need that gradient color so
here going to include that mixing
so we have the include
the name of that mixing is gradient
so i'm going to save let's see how the
section look like
so this is how the section looks like we
need to change the color
so on the html where we have the text
i'm going to add text white
on the row
then i'm going to save let's see
so much better now next i'm going to add
the background wave on this section
so from the layout you can see we have a
wave at the top of that
section and another wave at the bottom
of that section that means we have two
waves so we're going to generate that
from gatewaves dot io
and here we're going to make sure that
we generate something close or something
similar like what we have on the left
so here you're going to start with the
top wave so i'm going to change the
direction of the wave and then i'm going
to play around with this
icon till i find the one closed or
similar to the one you're looking for
so there it is i'm going to copy the
code
copy and then at the top of that section
i'm going to paste then i'm going to
change
the hex value to white
let's generate for the bottom section so
here i'm going to change the direction
and then i'm going to copy the code
again
and then at the bottom of that section
paste then i'm going to change the again
the x value to white
so we have the three f's or six f's i'm
going to save let's see
and now you can see that is our section
with the two
waves next i'm going to create the
carousel
so on the html i'm going to create
another row for that content
so i'm going to start with the comments
start the carousel
content
so here i'm going to start a new row
with a class of align item center
so to save time i'm going to copy an
example code from
the bootstrap documentation
so you can go to getbootstrap.com
so this one is the bootstrap component
so you can check on the components and
then
carousel so here i'm going to scroll
down till i find the one
that you're going to use so i'm going to
copy the code
for this one with captions so i'm going
to copy this code
and then i'm going to paste
so next thing i'm going to do is just
remove the
the two carousel items and then be left
to only one
so i'm going to remove the second one
and the third one
and then i'm going also to remove the
captions
and also the indicators so i'm going
also to remove the
indicators
also i'm going to remove the image and
this class for colossal caption
so i'm going to remove also that one
so now let's go ahead and add our own
carousel content
so if you check from the layout here we
have this container with the white
background and that is the container for
the text the two icons for the quotes
and
the stars then we have this client
picture and then the client name and
the role so that's how we're going to
nest it and here we're going to use
the block element modifier to nest it
that way
so first i'm going to list them the
three containers
so we have testimonials
underscore underscore card so this is
the container which will have the text
the stars and the two icons for the
quotes
then i'm going to commend them so that
we know where they start
so we have
testimonial
card
and then you're going to start again a
comment
we have the
client picture
so again we need a container for that
which is testimonials
underscore underscore picture
and then we need the client's name
enroll
so again testimonials
underscore underscore name
so inside the card you're going to start
with the text so we have a paragraph
with a class of
line height latch
then we need that icon that is the left
quote
so we have the icon and then the font or
some solid class
and then the name of that icon is quote
left
then some dummy text so we have lorem
21
and then we need the right quote
so i'm just going to copy the first one
and then this one is right
then we need the stars so we have a
class called ratings
so we have the icon and then the font or
some solid class
and then the name of that icon is star
so here i'm going to duplicate four more
times
two three four five
then i'm going to add the picture and
first i'm going to copy
the pictures to my project i already
have them
so here i have a folder called
testimonials you can see
we have client one to client five they
are in jpeg
so i'm going to copy the entire folder
to my project
so inside the images i'm going to paste
so now we can add the pictures so here i
have
an image with a class of image fluid
for responsive image and then
alt
so i'm going to write client minus
dollar sign or sign each value
picture
and then hit tab
so we have the source which is images
and then testimonials we have
client1.jpg
so i'm going to save
then we need to add the client name
so here i'm going to use h3
so let's see from the layout
so i'm going to start with cleveland so
that is the first
client just copy
actually we need to make sure that the
client name matches the name
so client one is a mail so that one
should not be that so i'm going to
change the name
so let me see again
so we have the name so i'm going to copy
that
paste then the client roll so here i'm
going to use the paragraph
with a class of lead
so what is the role see you in founder
ceo and founder
so actually this color should be font
with light
so i'm going to save we can see how it
looks like on the browser
so this is how the content looks like so
we're going to style it
so let's make sure that we add to the
rest of the
client items that is the testimonial or
carousel item so here i'm going to
comment
we have
carousel item one
then i'm going to duplicate carousel hm1
for the second client
so duplicate for the second client
and then i'm going to change the comment
to carousel item 2
and then change the client name so we
have client 2.
also the alt
so you're going also to change the name
so you can see from the layouts
we have joy marette finance manager
and then the role of that client is
finance manager
i'm going to duplicate carousel at m2
for the that client
so duplicate and then this one is
carousel item three
so we have client name three
client three for the alt
and then for the name so i'm going to
paste that name
and then the role is global finance
sorry global brand manager
so i'm going to duplicate corrosion item
3
for the fourth client
duplicates and then this one is
carousel 184
we have client for alt
client four and then the name
so best
so that is co ceo end founder
so i'm going to save let's say
so we have the corrosion items so the
buttons can't work
until we change the active class so the
only
corrosion item we need to be active is
the first one
so you can see here we have a crossover
active so we need to change
the rest so remove the active class
for the second third and the fourth one
so save
so now if you click the controls you'll
see
they are working
so the next step now is to style this
section so on testimonials.css you're
going to style it the way we have nested
on the html
so we're going to start
with the first one which is the card so
we have
the underscore underscore card
and then we have underscore underscore
picture
and then we have underscore underscore
name
so for the card we are going to set the
background color to white
so actually i'm going to use rgb
so we have the white color
with an opacity of 0.8
then we need some padding so i'm going
to set the padding to 2 ram
that is for the top and bottom and then
1.25
for the left and right
then we need the border radius
so i'm going to set that to 0.625
ram and then some height you're going to
set that to auto
so we need to align text at the center
so we have text align
center
so i'm going to save let's see how it
looks like so far
so that's how it's look like that is the
container for the text
and the two coats and the stars
also inside the card we're going to
style the two icons for the quotes
and the star ratings so here we have the
icon
and here i'm going to start with the
font size of that icon
so here i'm going to use 1.5 ram
and then the color
so i'm going to use rgba we have primary
with an opacity of 0.7
then we also need to style the star
ratings or the rating stars
so we have that class inside the card
also
and then the icon is inside the ratings
so we have
the icon and you're going to set the
color and the font size
so for the color going to copy what
you've used here on the
icons for the quotes
and then set the font size
we're going to use one ram
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
so there you have it you can see now
they have changed the color
next let's style the picture and here on
the picture i'm going to start by
setting
the wind and the height so you have wind
i'm going to set that to 6 ram we can
change that if it's too small or too
large
also the same with height
6 ram and then we need to set the
position to absolute
so i'm going to save let's see
so now that is the size of the picture
so we need to make it
circle or rounded so on the html we're
going to add that rounded circle class
on the image or the picture so i'm going
to select the four
classes
and then i'm going to add rounded circle
i'm going to save let's see
so now you can see our pictures around
it the next thing now is to position
these pictures
at the center of this white container
so back on the testimonials where we
have that picture
so here we're going to set left
we're going to use 50
then we have transform
translate we have minus 50 percent
minus 50
and then i'm going to save let's see
and as you can see that is the position
that you want it
so the next thing is to add the border
the rounded border
so here we have the image
and then we have the border
so wind i'm going to use 0.325 ram
solid and then color
we're going to use rgba
we have primary
with an opacity of 0.7
i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it you can see now
our picture has that border
next you're going to style the name
so we have the name here
so i'm going to start with the padding
top to give it some space
so we have padding top i'm going to use
forem
we need some margin at the bottom so we
have margin bottom
i'm going to use one ram
we need to align text at the center so
we have text align
center
then we need some font to it
so here i'm going to use 500
and then the color of the text
white
so then you can see
we're going to nest it they have down on
the html so we have h3
so here we can just set the padding top
to 0.8 ram so i'm going to save let's
see
and there you have it i think forum is a
bit it's too big
so let me change that to three
save so
there is better so the next thing
is to style the role
so before we go to the role we need to
add the text transform
so we need to set that to capitalize
and then we need now to style the role
so we have a paragraph
some padding at the bottom padding
bottom
you're going to set that to 2 ram
then text transform you're going to set
to capitalize
so i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it that is our role
so the only thing i'm going to do is put
some
padding on the stars so on the html
where we have the stars
i'm going to select all the classes for
ratings
the four of them at once and then i'm
going to add padding
one save let's see
so much better now
next i'm going to customize the controls
from the layout you can see we have the
controls at the bottom
so we're going to customize and replace
the defaults which are on the sides you
can see we have these
two controls on the sides so let's work
on that
so at the bottom here you're going to
remove the span
for the two
and then you're going to replace this
class carousel control
for the previous we're going to use the
btn classes
so here we have btn btn outline
outline lights and then we need that
icon
that is the font awesome icon so we have
the glass front or some solid
and then the name of that icon is
long arrow alt right so we have it here
so this one is left and then i'm going
to copy this class
to the next button or to the next class
paste and then
you need to change that to right
then i'm going to save let's see from
the browser
so now you can see we have the controls
but we need them at the center
so let also work on that so here i'm
going to put them
inside a container called the text
center so i'm going to select all of
them
the two and then add text center class
so we have text center
and then paste them inside that
container or that class
and then i'm going to save let's see
so now you can see we have the controls
at the center
and you can see once you click they are
moving to the next
glance or carousel item
so the next step now is to make sure
that our section is fully responsive so
i'm going to right click
and inspect elements
so first again to see how it looks like
on various devices you can see this one
is moto g4
again screen width 360.
and you can see the content is fitting
nicely on that
screen device so let's see from another
device
like pixel 2 again you can see
our content is fitting nicely
let's see from an ipad again you can see
the content is fitting nicely so even
without writing
the media breakpoints you can see our
section is
fully responsive so i'm going to look
from another device
like iphone 678 plus
and as you can see our section is fully
responsive
so with that we can move on to the next
section
welcome back in this video we are going
to create section 6 of the layout
which is the frequently asked questions
so we are going to use bootstrap
component called
accordion so once you click on the
question then the accordion collapses
and
reveals the item so let's get started
and create something similar like what
we have here on the layout
so on the html we are going to start
that section first is a comment we have
start section 6
the frequently asked questions
so i'm going to start the section with
an id of
frequently asked questions faq and a
class of faq
we need a container
and also arrow
tab so here you're going to start
with the heading and then the heading
line and then the subheading
so here we have h1 with a class of
display three
and a class of font-weight bold
so we have faq and here we also need to
add another class which is
text capitalize or text uppercase
you can see up we have that class text
uppercase
and also on the row we need to add the
text center class
after the heading we have that heading
line so we have that class
heading line
and then the sub heading which is a
paragraph with a class of lead
so i'm going to copy
and then paste and then i'm going to
save let's see
from the browser
and there you have it you have it you
can see now we have that heading
next i'm going to add the accordion
content so
on the html i'm going to create a new
row for that content
so we have the comment which is
accordion
content
so i'm going to start a new row
and some margin at the top so i'm going
to choose margin top 5
and then here you need to specify the
column size that you want to use
so that one will reflect on the size of
the accordion that you're going to have
so for now we can use call md 12.
so that one will go full length
so to save time i'm going to copy the
example code from the bootstrap
documentation
so you can go to get bootstrap.com and
then under the components you'll find
accordion so here there are two examples
that you can copy we have the first one
and then we have the second one called
the accordion flash
so this one removes the default
background color some borders and some
rounded corners to render accordions
edge to edge with their parent container
so i'm going to copy the example for the
first one
so i'm going to copy the entire code and
then paste
and there you have it so here because we
have four
accordion items you can see from the
layout
you can see we have four so we need to
duplicate one
which is the third so we have from here
i'm going to duplicate for the fourth
accordion item
so once you duplicate you must change
some
things like the id attributes you can
see here
collapse 3 we need to change that to 4.
also you need to change the area
labeled by so you need to change that to
4.
also this one is three is four
then i'm going to save let's see from
the browser
and that is our content so once you
click then
the accordion collapses and reveals the
item
so we have according to accordion item
two we have accordion item three and
finally accordion item
four so let's comment this accordion
item so that you can know where they
start
let's start with the first one so we
have accordion item one
so i'm going to comment that
accordion item one
that is a comment
so i'm going to copy that comment for
the rest of the accordion items
we have the second one
we have the third one
and finally we have the fourth
so now we are ready to customize the
accordion
so here we're going to customize a few
things if you check from the layout here
we're going to add
some space between the accordion items
so that we can separate the accordion
items and then you're going to add
shadow
and then you're going to add some
padding between the questions
and then also we need to change the
question to reflect what we have here on
the left
so let's work on that so first i'm going
to
select all the accordion items so that
we can add the two classes
so we're going to add shadow
and then you're going to separate or add
some space between the accordion items
by using margin
bottom so we have margin bottom three
so i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it you can see now we
have some space between the accordion
items and then
that shadow so the next one is to make
sure that the questions reflect what we
have here on the left
so we have the first question so i'm
going to copy
so i have changed the question i'm going
to save let's say from the browser
so now you can see the questions reflect
what you have there on the layout
so the next one is to add some padding
between the questions
so here we have accordion padding x and
accordion padding y
so to do that you're going to override
some of the bootstrap defaults
so you're going to go to the variables
file which can be found inside the node
modules
and that is the bootstrap variables file
and then bootstrap
scss and then down here you have that
file
variables.css
so here on the variables where we have
the accordion we're going to copy
the two variables that is according
padding y and you can see the default is
one ram
and according paddingx and the default
is 1.2
ram so i'm going to copy the two
variables
and then inside the custom
so where we have the according overheads
i'm going to add that
variables and then i'm going to remove
the two defaults
or the default flag so here you're going
to override
according padding y to 1.5 and also
according padding x we're going also to
override that to 1.5
so both are going to use 1.5 ram so i'm
going to save
let's see and there you have it you can
see now
we have that padding and that is what we
have here on the layout
so you can see the space is the same
next is to make sure that our section is
fully responsive so i'm going to right
click and
inspect element so this is how the
section look like
on a screen window of 360. that's
moto g4 and you can see the content is
fitting nicely
so i'm going to change to another screen
device like ipad
ipad again you can see our content is
fitting nicely on that
screen device so let's change to another
one like
iphone 6 7 8 plus
again you can see our content is fitting
nicely so even without
creating or writing any media breakpoint
our section is fully responsive
so we can move on to the next section
welcome back in this video we are going
to create section 7 of the layout which
is the portfolio
so here going to showcase some of the
latest projects that our fake
company has created so here we have some
buttons
and then once you hover the project
you'll see they reveal the project name
and the category of that project so
let's get started and create something
similar like what you have here on the
layout
so on the html i'm going to start that
section
and i'm going to start with the comment
as always so we have stat
section 7
the portfolio
so let's start that section with an idea
of
portfolio
and a class of portfolio
we need a container
and a row tab
so here going to start with the heading
we have the latest work and then heading
line and then subheading
so we have h1 with a class of
display three and a class of font-weight
bold
so latest work
so here i'm going also to add another
class which is text capitalize
and then the heading line below the
heading so we have
heading line
then the subheading we have the
paragraph with the class of lead
some dummy text so lorem 12
save let's see
so we have our text now so let's put it
on the center at the center
so here on the row i'm going to add text
center class
save let's see so there you have it
but now we need some space between the
the previous section and the heading
so on the row here i'm going to add some
margin at the top so we have
margin top five
save let's see
so now you can see we have some space
between the previous section and
that heading next i'm going to add
the filter buttons so we have these
buttons for filtering the categories
so let's add the buttons
so here i'm going to add another row for
that content so we have
filter buttons
so a neuro with a class of text center
and then a column so we're going to use
call md12
so here we have button
with a class of btn
and then btn outline primary
and the type of the button is button
so we have type which is button
so so we have all
and then i'm going to duplicate for the
categories
so the second category is websites
the next one is design and then we have
mockup
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
and now you can see we have the buttons
so what you're going to do is add some
margin at the top so that you can have
some space between the
heading the subheading and the buttons
so here we have the row we are going to
add margin top
three and then save let's see
so i think we need to increase the
margin so here i'm going to use margin
top five
and then margin bottom four and then
some gutter so we're going to use gutter
three
and then save
so now you can see we have some enough
space
next i'm going to add the content for
their portfolio items
from the layout here we have the nine
columns which make up the nine portfolio
items
first i'm going to copy the portfolio
images or the pictures to my project
so here i have a folder called portfolio
it has all the pictures for the
portfolio
they are named portfolio one all the way
to portfolio nine
and they are in jpeg so i'm going to
copy the entire folder to my project
so inside the images paste
so now we have the pictures in our
project now we can go ahead and add
the portfolio items all that content
so here you're going to create a new row
for that content
so i'm going to start with a comment
which is that
the portfolio content or portfolio items
so here i'm going to create a new row
and here i'm going to use emit to help
us generate
the 9 portfolio items at once so after
draw we need the columns
and here i'm going to group them and i'm
going to create two
breakpoints for large devices i'm going
to use
call lg4
and then for medium devices i'm going to
use call md6
then we need the container for all the
portfolio items
so i'm going to call it portfolio box
and then we need shadow so i'm going to
add that shadow class
and then we need the picture or the
image
so here again i'm going to group the
picture the picture so we have the image
and then the source of the images
so we have a folder called images and
then portfolio
where we have the pictures
so here we need the name of the files so
we have
portfolio minus
dollar sign dot jpg
so the dollar sign will assign each
value so that
we can have portfolio one to portfolio
nine
and they are in jpeg formats then we
need the
alt so we have portfolio
dollar sign image
and then also we need the title so we
have
title
so we have portfolio
dollar sign picture
then we need the class for responsive
image so we're going to use
image fluid that one is a bootstrap
response a
bootstrap class for responsive images
so we have image fluid
then from there we need the container
for the caption so i'm going to call it
portfolio info
and then we need the caption so we're
going to create another class
so we have div and then caption
then from there we need the
the caption so we're going to use h4
so we have h4 and the text will be
project name
goes here and then dollar sign
and also the category project you have
the p
and then the text will be category
project
so at the end here i'm going to say
times nine
and it's going to generate for us all
the nine portfolio items
with the content so here you can specify
the number of
columns or the portfolio items that you
want it to generate so we have nine so
i'm going to say times nine
hit tab and here you can see now it has
generated for us all the contents
including the pictures and it has a send
also the values so i'm going to save
let's see from the browser
and there you have it you can see now we
have the nine portfolio items
next i'm going to style the content and
we have a sass file for that
section which is portfolio.css so i'm
going to open that file
and here the first thing i'm going to do
is to use the module
so we have the use
and then custom that is the first module
you're going to use because of the
variables
so use it at the start and then
also we're going to use the mixing
so we have components and then mixing
so again use it as star and then close
so here i'm going to start by styling
the class called
portfolio
so this is the class we have on the
section if we check from the html we
have that class
here on the section
so here i'm going to set the padding
and i'm going to set 4m for the top and
bottom
and then 0 for the left and right
then you're going also to style the
text on the buttons so we need to set
the
text transform to capitalize
so we have the button
so text transform capitalize
i'm going to save let's see
so now we have the text set to
capitalize and you can see now they are
capitalized
so the next thing is to style the
portfolio box and that one is a
standalone
container so we have portfolio
box so here i'm going to start with the
position
i'm going to set that to relative
then we're going to set the width
200 percent so the width is going to
scale to the
wind of the columns so remember here on
the html we have
the two columns we have call lg4 and
column d6
so those are two different breakpoints
and then also the height we're going to
set that to
18.5 ram
we can change that later to bigger too
small
so that means all our portfolio items
will have an equal height
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
so now you can see we have equal height
on all portfolio items
so the next thing is to style the images
or the pictures to scale to the height
of the portfolio box so here we're going
to style it
inside the portfolio box we have the
image
and here i'm going to set the width and
the height to 100 percent
100 and also height
so the height of the image is going to
scale to the
height of the parent container which is
the
portfolio box and we have set that to
18.5 ram
so we have 100 save
let's see so now you can see the
pictures are scaled to the height of the
parent container so the next thing is to
hide
some of the caption you can see they're
overflowing
so here you're going to use a property
called overflow
and you're going to set that to hidden
save let's see
and there you have it you can see now
they are hidden
let's also add some margin at the bottom
so that we can separate the
portfolio items
so here we're going to set the margin
bottom
to 1.2 ram
save let's see and
there you have it you can see now we
have some margin at the bottom
to separate the portfolio items
next i'm going to style the captions and
also add the border at the top
so if you check here from the layout you
can see we have a board at the top
and the captioning is only visible once
you hover the portfolio item
so let's work on that
so here we're going again to nest it the
way we have done on the html so we have
the portfolio info
inside the portfolio box so we have that
class
so this is the class or the container
which has that background
color so we have here going to set that
background color
so we have rgba so we have our primary
an opacity of 0.75
and then i'm going to set the width and
the height 200 percent
so we have width 100 percent
and also height
also here i'm going to set the position
to absolute
and then we have the caption inside
the portfolio info so we have that class
so here i'm going to set the text align
to center
so i'm going to save let's see
so nothing to show so here we're going
to set the top
to zero
so we need to set that top zero
and then i'm going to save let's see
so now you can see we have the caption
and that's background so the next thing
is to position
the caption at the center of the
portfolio item
so on the caption you're going to
include that mixer so we have
include which is going to position it at
the center
and you have that mixing code absolute
center
going to save let's see so now you can
see we have the caption at the center
so let's change the color
so we have white close
save let's see and
there you have it so let's change
or set detect text transform to
uppercase
so that we can make sure that the
caption are in uppercase like what you
have here on the left
so let's set that so inside the caption
we have that h4
so text transform we're going to set
that to uppercase
and then i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it
next we need to hide the captions and
only make them visible
once you hover the portfolio item
so here we have the container for the
caption which is portfolio info
so here we need to set the opacity to
zero
and also visibility to hidden so we have
opacity 0 and then
visibility i'm going to set that to
hidden so i'm going to save let's see
so now you can see the captions have
been hidden
so we need the caption to be visible
once you hover
the portfolio item so down here we're
going to create that over
so we have the hoover effect
and then you're going to call this class
portfolio
and then you're going to set the opacity
to 1
and visibility to visible so opacity
1 and visibility
visible
i'm going to save let's see
so now if you hover the portfolio time
you can see
the captions are visible
the next thing is to add the border top
at the top we need the board at the top
like what we have here on the left
so you can see we have that board at the
top so let's also
set that so we need it
at the portfolio box so border
top i'm going to use 0.5 frame
for the wind solid
and then the color we're going to use
purple light so we have that color on
the customs as well
purple light
i'm going to save let's see
so you can see now we have that border
at the top
so something else i'm going to do is to
create a transition which you're going
to apply on the hoover effect so you can
see once you hover the
portfolio item that hover is so dry
so let's create a transition which
you're going to apply so that we can
have that smooth hoover effect
on the portfolio items
so here we're going to create a mixing
which you're going to use
where we need to use that transition so
i'm going to open that mixing
and then down here we're going to create
that
mixing so i'm going to start with a
comment which is
transition
property
so we have the mixing art mixing
and the name of that mixing i'm going to
call it
transition property
so we are going to use transition
duration
so we have that and here i'm going to
set to 1000 milliseconds
another property you need is the
transition property so
we have transition property
so i'm going to set to all and then i'm
going to save
then you're going to include this mixing
where we have that hoover effect
or any other place that you want to use
that transition
so we have the portfolio and then here
i'm going to include
that mixing so we have include
and then transition
property
so i'm going to save let's say from the
browser
so now you can see once i hover the
portfolio item you can see we have that
smooth
over effect or that smooth transition
so something else before we finish this
part is to
i'm going to set where we have the
portfolio
info so we have top zero and left
zero so i'm going to set also that
to zero and then where we have
that caption the heading i'm going to
set
the display to block
so i'm going to save
so now if you hover the portfolio you
can see
we have that smooth effect
so before i finish up on the portfolio
i'm going to do a few changes on the
height
of the images because you're going to
have some issues on the height of the
images on smaller devices
so i'm going to right click and then i'm
going to click on inspect
elements
so especially on medium devices you can
see this one is a medium device and you
can see the height is not scaling nicely
so i'm going to rotate
this width or the screen
and here you'll see just like i said
you're going to have some issues with
the height of the images
they're not scaling nicely on different
devices
so to make that work we're going to use
maximum width
on the height where we have the
portfolio box
so instead of the height we're going to
set that using the max height
so i'm going to set that max height
which is going to scale to 18.5 ram
and then on the image i'm going to
remove the height
so i'm going just to comment it and then
i'm going to save
let's see whether it will fix that so
save let's see
so now just like i said you can see now
the images are scaling nicely
that is the height of the images so we
don't have issues now with the height
of the images on medium devices
so i'm going to close the inspector and
then i'm going to resize the browser
window
so you can see now we don't have the
issues with the height of the images
they are scaling nicely
so something else is we need to add
where we have the image that is on hover
we need to scale the images a bit
so where we have that hoover pseudo
class
we're going to add we're going to scale
the images
so we have transform
and then scale and then i'm going to
scale that to 1.5
so i'm going to save let's see
so close that before we do we save and
then save
so now if you hover the images you can
see they are scaling a bit so i'm going
to
enlarge the browser window
welcome back in this video we're going
to create section 8 of the layout which
is the get started also known as cta or
call to action section so here you're
going to start with the heading and then
you're going to create the two equal
columns
with the left column having the cta info
and then the right
or the second column having the form so
let's get started and create something
similar like what we have on the left
so on the html i'm going to start that
section
so i'm going to start with the comment
as always so we have start
section 8
get started
so we have that section
with a with an id of contacts
and a class of get started
we need a container
and arrow
tab so here going to start with the
heading
so we have h1 with a class of display
three
and a class of it bold
and a class of text capitalize
so we have that text get started
then on the row here we need to add the
text center class
so text center
so after the heading we need the heading
line so we have that class
heading line
and then the subheading so we have p
with a class of line heights
large and then some dummy text we have
lorem 12
and then i'm going to save let's see
from the browser so far
so now we have that text
next i'm going to style this section and
here we're going to set some padding
and some background color so you can see
here from the layout
we're going to use this a gray color
so let's work on that so we have a file
for that section which is
get started so i'm going to open that
file
and here the first thing i'm going to do
is to use the modules so we have the
custom module and the mixing module so
we have the use
and then custom
so again use it as star
also we need the mixing so we have again
use
components mixing
use as star
so i'm going to style the class we have
on the section which is
the get started so we have this class
so here i'm going to set some padding
top and bottom i'm going to set that to
4m
and then left and right 0 then the
background color
we're going to use one of the gray
colors
so here i'm going to use gray 200.
then i'm going to save let's see from
the browser
so there you have it next i'm going to
create the two columns
from the left here we have the two
columns we have the left column with
this gradient background
which will have the cta info and then we
have the red column with this
white background which will have the
form so let's work on that
so on the html i'm going to create a new
row for that content
first let's start with a comment which
is start
the cta info or the cta content
so i'm going to start a new row
which will have the two columns so we
have a row with a class of text white
and then we have the two columns so i'm
going to group them
i'm going to start with call 12 and
another column
which i'm going to use called lg 6. then
here at the end i'm going to say
times two hit tab
so on the first column we're going to
have that gradient background
and then on the second column we're
going to have that white background
so on the first column i'm going to add
a class called gradient which you're
going to create in a moment
so gradient and then also shadow
and some padding so i'm going to use p
padding 3. and then on the second column
we are going to have
white background so we have bg white
and then some shadow
and also padding three
then i'm going to create that gradient
and we already have that
mixing so i'm going to go to that file
mixing.css
so you're going to copy this gradient
and then create it
as a class so i'm going to copy
and then on typography you're going to
create it on that file
so here we have our comment
which is gradient bg
and then we have that class gradient
and then paste so i'm going to save
let's see how it looks like on the
browser
so now you can see the two columns we
have the left which has this
gradient and then the right which has
this white background
next now we are going to add the content
so inside the html
on the first column we are going to
create a class called
cta info so this one will be the
container for
all the content that you're going to put
on the first column
so we have cta info and then
we're going to set the width 200 percent
so we have w100
so here we're going to start with the
content for
left column so we have this hundred
percent
satisfaction guarantee so i'm going to
copy that text
and then i'm going to start h4 with a
class of display four
and a class of font-weight bold
and then paste that text the next text
you're going to add
is the paragraph so we have this dummy
text
so we have paragraph with a class of
line height large and then some dummy
text so we have lorem
21
and then after the paragraph we have
this sub heading
and then the list
so here i'm going to have h3 with a
class of display
3 and i'm going to modify that with
brief
so we're going to style it later and
then the text
and then from there we need the list so
we have ul
that is another list with a class of cta
info underscore underscore
list
and then we have the list items so we
have the li
and then some dummy text lorem ipsum
and then here i'm going to say times
gray
hit tab and now we have the
text so i'm going to save let's see how
it looks on the browser
so now we have the content so here we
need to make sure that they reflect what
we have here on the
layout so i'm going to copy
the contents so we have
the first list item paste
so i've copied all the text or the list
items
so i'm going to save and check on the
browser
so now we have that text the next the
next step is to style
this content so on the sas file
that is the get started.css we are going
to create that
container that is the cta info
cta info
so remember this is the container for
all the content on the left column
so we have that city info
so here i'm going to set the padding
to three ram all sides
and then i'm also going to set the
margin
one ram top and bottom and then zero
left and right
from there going to style the list
so we have underscore underscore list
so here i'm going to start by setting
the position to relative
then i'm going to set the list style
type to none
and then display we're going to set that
to
block
so i'm going to save let's say from the
browser
so that is how the content looks like
now
next i'm going to style the list items
from the layout here you can see
the list item are using this check icon
and here we're going to use the unicode
for this
check icon so on the sas file you're
going to nest it the way you have done
on the html so we have the list item
inside
the class list so we have the li
and then content before because the
check icon must come before the list
items
so here you're going to start with the
font family and you're going to use
the font awesome file free so we have
the double quotes
and then fonts awesome
five free
then the contents
and just like i said you're going to get
the unicode from font or some
documentation so
we have that cheat sheet that is the
front of some cheat sheet
so here you're going to search for that
icon
so i'm just going to type check
and then it's going to list for us all
the versions of the check icon
and you can see here we have that icon
and then the unicode so the unicode of
that
icon is f00c so i'm going to copy that
then on the content we're going to add
the double quotes
and then the backslash and then the
unicode
like that then we need to set the font
to it
and here you must set any value from 600
and above so i'm going to use 600
then i'm going to save let's see from
the browser how it looks like
and there you have it now you can see we
have the check icon on the list items
the next step now is to add some padding
and some space between the icon
and the list items
so here i'm going to set margin right
so i'm going to use 0.5 ram
and then also set the font size
so i'm going to use 1.2 ram
and then on the list that is the list
class
i'm going to set paddingtop i'm going to
use 0.5
ram
and then
padding left i'm going to use 0.5 also
and then some margin at the bottom
i'm going to use 0.7 ram
so i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it now you can see we
have some enough space between
the content next i'm going to add the
content for the second column
so from the layout here we have this
heading that says start your project
and then the form so let's work on that
so here just like we did with the first
column i'm going to create a container
for
that content so i'm going to call this
container form
and then we're going to set the width
200 percent so we have w
100 and then some padding at the bottom
so we have padding bottom two
so we're going to start with that
heading and here we're going to use the
same heading that we used on the
services
so just to show you where we have that
heading on the services
you can see we have this heading with
the background clip
so these are two colors so we're going
to use the same heading
on that part
so i'm going to have h4 with a class of
display three and you're going to modify
that with title
and then some margin at the bottom so
you have margin bottom
five so you have that text
which is start your project
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
so now you can see we have that heading
next let's start the
form
so before i add the form i must mention
that in the new version that is booster
version 5
they dropped the use of the form group
class so here we're going to use
one of the utility classes to wrap up
our form
or the input fields so we have the form
and then the action
we're going to have that for now and
then we have the
class row
so we have so here we're going to use
margin bottom
three so you must have that class so
mp3 and then the inputs
this one is for the first name and we
have
the type of the input which is text
and then we need the placeholder
so the placeholder is first name
and then you also need the id
input first name
and then we need the class form control
so i'm going to hit tab
so here i'm going to duplicate for the
last name
and then i'm going to change the
placeholder to last name
and also the inputs
and then i'm going also to duplicate
again for the email
so this one the input type is an email
placeholder email
address
so we have the id input email
and then i'm going to duplicate for the
message
so the type is
actually it is not an input it's a text
area so i'm going to remove that
and then add text area
so the name message
id message
and then you're going to add the class
so i'm going to copy this form control
and then add it on the text area
and here we just only need rows eight
so i'm going to set from ten to eight
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser how it looks like
so this is our form so we need to add
some shadow and then make sure that our
input feeder large
like what we have here on the layout
so i'm going to select the class for the
four of them
and then i'm going to add shadow
and then we need also to add another
class so i'm going to select
and add form control large
so this one is from control so i'm going
to save let's see
so now you can see our form
so we need to add the placeholder where
we have the message
so i'm going to copy
save let's see and there you have it
the next one let's add the button
text center so we have that class
and then also going to set the display
to grid
so we have d grid and then
some margin at the top so we have margin
top one
and then now we need that button so we
have
button and the type of the button
is button
and then the class we have btn
btn primary
and then rounded rounded pill
and then we have
padding top
three and also padding top
sorry padding bottom three so we have pb
three so so that you can have some space
between the content so i'm going to hit
sub
and then here we're going to add submit
so let's see save
and there you have it now you can see we
have that button
next you're going to add the you can see
we have an icon
so we're going to add that icon
so that one should come after the text
so we have
the icon and then the class font or some
solid
and then the name of that icon is
paper plane
save let's say and there you have it
next i'm going to style this content
so on the get started so here i'm going
to start with the comments
so we have the form content
so we have that class form and here i'm
going to set
the padding so we have
i'm going to set padding to three ram
so remember here on the cta info we set
that to 3 ram also
so i'm going to set that to 3 ram and
then you're going to style
the button so you have the button inside
the form
so here i'm going to set the border to
none
and then we have the color i'm going to
use white
and then we're going to style any link
we're going to start with the color
which i'm going to set that to white
and then text decoration we're going to
set that to none also
and then text transform i'm going to set
that to capitalize
so i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it you can see now we
have our content
next let's make sure that our form looks
similar like what we have on the left
and that is to have the first name and
the last name in one row so here i'm
going to create two equal columns which
is going to split the two
and also make our form fully responsive
so let's work on that
so remember here we have a class called
row that means any column that you put
inside the row will be displayed using
flex
so for the first name and the last name
i'm going to select the two classes
and then here i'm going to add a column
which is going to split the two
on large devices only and then on any
other device then they're going to go to
full width
so i'm going to use call lg6
and then for the email address and the
message i'm going to use
call lg 12. that means they'll go full
width regardless of the screen width
so we have call lg12
save so let's see
so here you can see already we have the
first name and the last name
being split into two and this one will
only
happen on large devices only so i'm
going to right click and inspect
elements
so you can see this one is a device with
a screen window of 360 and you can see
already the first name and the last name
are going full width
so it's only on large devices where
you're going to have the first name and
the last name
split into two so i'm going to change to
another device and this one will be a
medium device like an ipad
and this is a screen window of 768 and
you can see the input field are going
full length
we can even do the same way we have done
on large devices where we have the first
name and the last name
split into two so here going to add
a column which is going to create that
media breakpoint for medium devices
so here i'm going to add call md6
and then i'm going to save let's see
and there you have it you can see now on
medium devices
we have two columns or two columns for
the first name and the last name
and they are in the same row
so with that i think our form is fully
responsive across
variety of screen devices
welcome back in this video we're going
to create section 9 of the layout which
is the footer
and on the footer we have four parts of
the footer we have the top footer
which has the contact info we have the
mobile email and the location
and then we have the social media part
and then we have the company info and
then at the bottom we have the copyright
information
so let's get started and create
something similar like what we have on
the layouts
so on the html i'm going to start that
section
and i'm going to start with a comment as
always
so we have start
section 9 the footer
so here i'm going to to start that
section so we have footer
with a class of footer and a container
and then i'm going to hit tab and then
you're going to style that
class so i'm going to save and then
on the sas file for that section which
is the footer.sss i'm going to open that
file
and then the first thing i'm going to do
is to use the modules
so we have the first one which is the
custom
so custom and then use it
as star
then we also have the mixing so we have
the use
components and then mixing
use it as star
so here i'm going to style the footer we
have that class already
and here i'm going to set paddingtop
i'm going to set that to one ram
then the background color
so here we're going to create this color
we don't have it on the custom source
file
so here i'm going to create a variable
called footer specifically for that
section so i'm going to save and then
we need to create this variable on the
custom sauce file so i'm going to open
that file
so this is a new color so i'm going to
add it where we have the
white and the gray colors let me just
add on
my theme colors so we have variable
footer and then i'm going to assign it
this color that is one f151
close and then i'm going to save let's
see from the browser
and there you have it at the bottom here
you can see we have that color
so we're going to start with the top
footer
which has this contact info we have the
icon
the phone the working hours and then
we have the email icon the email and
then we have the location and the icon
so you're going to start with that
footer
so in the html i'm going to use emmett
to generate
the three sections at once
so here i'm going to start a new row and
then i'm going to add
the columns so i'm going to group them
and here i'm going to use columns that
are going to create
different breakpoints for medium devices
i'm going to use
call md4
for large devices i'm going to use call
lg4
and then we need the container for all
that content so i'm going to call it
contact box
then we need some padding at the top so
i'm going to add that class padding top
one
and then we need the container for the
icon you can see here
from the layout you have the icon the
title and the subtitle same way with
email and
the location so here we're going to use
block element modifier to nest it
so again we have that class
contact box and then underscore
underscore icon
so that one will be the container for
the icon
and then we need the container for the
title and the subtitle so here i'm going
to add a plus
and then again contact box
and that's called underscore info so the
info will have
the title and the subtitle then i'm
going to add
the title so we have the link with the
class of contact box
underscore underscore info and then i'm
going to modify that with
title so we have minus minus title
and then we have the text so i'm going
to have
title goes here so we're going to
replace that with the actual content
for that title and then
we need the subheading so here we're
going to use paragraph
with the class of contact box
and that's called underscore info minus
minus
subtitle
so the text we're going to use
subtitle
goes here again you're going to replace
that with the actual contents
so here at the end i'm going to say
times three
and then it's going to generate for us
or the three section
or the three columns at once with the
content so hit tab
and now you can see we have the first
container that is for the
phone or the mobile number and then we
have the second one
for the email and then the third one for
the location so i'm going to comment
them so that we can know where they
start
so we have the first column so it's i'm
going to say stats
or just content
for the phone or for the mobile number
and then we have contact for email
content for email
and then you have the that one which is
content
for
location
so i'm going to save let's see how it
looks like on the browser
so that is our content looks like so far
so we're going to style it
you can see we have the title goes here
for the first one
the second one and the third one next
i'm going to add the icons
from the layout here you can see we have
the phone icon
for the phone content we have the mail
icon for the email content and then we
have the location icon for the location
content
and these are svg icons and i must
mention that there are different sources
that you can get these
svg icons but if you want to use the
same icons that have used here then you
need to go to
tableau icons.com so you're going to
start with the first icon which is the
phone
icon so we're just going to type phone
and by doing that you'll be able to see
that icon and you can see it here
the name of that icon is phone call so
i'm going to click it to copy the svg
code
so click and you can see now it says
copied
and then on the first column where we
have the container for the icon i'm
going to paste
that code there so paste
next we need the icon for the email
so again you're going to type or search
for that icon
so i'm just going to type email
and here you can see we have that icon
you can see it here mail opened that is
the name of that icon so i'm going to
click it to copy
the code so again where we have the
icon
that is the content for email we have
that container
paste the next one is the location icon
so i'm going to search for that so again
on the table icons i'm going to
search for location
and by doing that you'll be able to see
the icon and you can see it here the
name of that icon is map2
that is map -2 copy
and then on the icon container i'm going
to paste
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser how it looks like
and there you have it you can see now we
have the three icons
so let's also replace the titles the
subtitle with the actual content that we
have on the left
so let's start with the phone number so
i'm going to copy
so i'm going to
[Music]
and then we have the subtitle which is
the working hours
so let's do the same for the email and
the location so copy
so i've copied that let's also do the
same for the location
so i've replaced all the content so i'm
going to save let's see
and there you have it now you can see we
have the actual content
so the next step nice to style the
content
so we already have a sass file for that
section which is footer.sss
so here you're going to style the
contact box which is the container for
that content
so let's start with the comment which is
style
the contact box
content
so we have that class contact box
so here i'm going to set the position to
relative
then you're going to style it the way we
have nested on the html
so from the html you can see we have
this class
which is contact box underscore
underscore icon
and then we have contact box underscore
underscore info
which has the title and the subtitle
so that's how we're going to style it so
let's start with the icon we have
underscore underscore icon
and then another one is
info so you have underscore underscore
info
which you're going to modify the title
and the subtitle
so for the title we're going to modify
that
so we have minus minus title
and then also for the subtitle
minus minus subtitle
so here i'm going to start with the
width and i'm going to set the width and
the stroke
that means on the html where we have the
three icons
we need to remove a few things and one
of them is the wind and the height you
can see it's already set to 444
and also remove the stroke and that is
the color
of that stroke so let's start with the
wind and the height so i'm going to
select and then
target the three icons so you have the
second
and then that one backspace
and then also the stroke color
so we have the stroke color so i'm going
to remove it
and then for the stroke wind you're
going to set that to one so i'm going to
remove the five
and then save then you can go ahead and
set
the width of the icon so here i'm going
to set the width
so i'm going to use 4m
and then the stroke
i'm going to use primary
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
and there you have it you can see now we
have the three icons
and the color of the icon has changed to
purple so next let's style the title and
the subtitle so for the info we're going
to set the padding
so i'm going to set the parting to 0.4
ram
and then for the title let's start with
the color
that is white
and then text decoration
none
and then for the subtitle
let's set the color
so we're going to use one of the gray
colors you can see from the layouts
we have this gray color so we're going
to use one of the gray colors
so here we have gray 300
so that is the color we're going to use
and then we need also to set
text decoration to none
and also not forgetting the font size of
the title and the subtitle so for the
title we're going to set
the font size to one ram
or 1.4
and then font size for the subtitle
you're going to set that to one ram
so i'm going to save let's see
so that is how the content looks like i
think gray 300 is not the correct
color so let's try
gray 600
save let's see and there you have it
so something else is we need to set the
font weight
of the title and the subtitle you can
see they are a bit bold
so i'm going to
set here for the info so you have font
to it
i'm going to use 600 save
let's see
so much better now next i'm going to set
the display for this content
and this will create different
breakpoints so that we can target
different screen devices and this will
also make our content fully responsive
so on the html where we have the three
columns i'm going to select the
three and then here we're going to add
the display
utility classes which are going to
create different breakpoints
so for medium devices i'm going to set
the display to block so we have d
and then medium and then block
for large devices we're going to set the
display to flex so we have display
large flex and then for small devices
you're going to set the display to flex
or any other device
so you have display flex
so i'm going to save let's say from the
browser
so you can see now the display has
changed you can see now on large devices
it
is using the display flex so i'm going
to right click so that we can check
for other devices and inspect elements
so you can see here these are this one
is a medium device it's an ipad with a
screen window of 768 you can see
the display has set to block so you can
see the icon is on top of the title and
says the subtitle
that means that display is working on
that device
so let's see from a small device so i'm
going to switch device
let's go for moto g4 so again here you
can see
the display is set to flex so i'm going
to switch to another device
another small device like galaxy s5
again you can see the display is set to
flex
so the only thing you're going to do
here is to reduce the for the width of
the icons on small devices
and medium devices
so here i'm going to add a media
breakpoint which is going to target
large devices only
so on the footer where we have that icon
i'm going to add the midi breakpoint so
we have include
media breakpoints
up and here you're going to to target
from small device
and then you're going to set the width
to 4m
so copy paste then
on small device you're going to set that
to 2 ram
so i'm going to save let's see and now
you can see the
icons have reduced the size
so the next thing is to also reduce the
title and the subject on small devices
so again here we're going to create
create or include a midi breakpoint
which is which is going to target large
devices
so i'm going to copy that media
breakpoint and then add it where we have
the title
so here you're going to set the font
size to 1.4 m
and then one ram for small devices
so this one will also apply to subtitles
so i'm also going to copy
where we have the subtitle so we need to
include that media breakpoint
and then where we have
large devices are going to have one ram
and then we are going to reduce
the font size on small devices to weight
0.8
and then i'm going to save or 0.9
let's see and there you have it you can
see now we have
the title and the subtitle they're a bit
small
so let's switch to another device let's
go for a medium device we have an ipad
so again you can see the content is
fully responsive
let's go for a large device ipad pro
again you can see the content is fully
responsive
so here i'm going to switch back to a
small device
and here the only thing i'm going to do
is to make sure that the icon and the
title are
lining together so i'm going to add some
padding where we have the icon
so we have padding top
so i'm going to set the padding top to
0.5
ram so save let's see
and there you have it i think we need
also to
reduce the font size of the subtitle so
i think
0.9 is a bit large so here i'm going to
set to 0.8
and then save let's see
so now i think everything is perfectly
fine so
on all devices our content now is fully
responsive
so we can move on to the next step
next i'm going to create the content for
the second part of the footer which is
the social media
so on the html i'm going to create a
container for that content
so here i'm going to start with a
comment which is start
the social media content
so here i'm going to create a class
called footer social media
so you have footer dash social media
so i'm going to use the two initials
and then here going to style the
background you can see here we have this
light background
so i'm going to add an inline style so
we have style
we have background color
and then i'm going to use 21 21 21 so
that is the hex value for that color
then from there we need a container a
row and the two columns you can see here
we have
the two columns we have the first column
with this content that says connect with
us on social media
and then we have another column for the
social icons
or for the social media icons so we have
a container
and a row and then i'm going to add some
padding so we have padding y
i'm going to set that to 4
and then text center so we need to add
that class
and then tab so here i'm going to create
two and equal columns which are going to
create
different breakpoints so from the left
you can see we have the first column
which has this text that says connect
with us on social media
and then we have the second column which
has these social media icons
so here for large devices i'm going to
use call
lg5 that is for the first column
and then for medium devices i'm going to
use call md6
and then some margin at the bottom so
you need to add that class margin bottom
4 tab and then paste that text
then for the second column on large
devices i'm going to use call
lg 7 so that they make it 12 so we have
caller g7 and then color g5 for the
first column
and for medium devices i'm going to use
call md6
and then tab
so here we're going to start with the
facebook icon
and then twitter github linkedin and
then instagram
so we're going to create them in that
order
so here we have the link and then the
icon
and then here we're going to use the
font awesome brand class
and then the name of that icon is
facebook
and then tab so i'm going to duplicate
for
the rest of the icons
so for the second icon we have twitter
that icon we have
linkedin sorry we have github
and then for the fourth one we have
linkedin
so we have linkedin
and then the fifth one we have
instagram
so you have instagram and then i'm going
to save let's see from the browser
and there you have it you can see now we
have that text
oh sorry those icons but we don't see
the text so here we need to add the
class
text white so here we have the row i'm
going to add
text white
and then save let's see
and there you have it so the next step
now is to style
that content so the footer.css
we're going to style that class so at
the bottom here i'm going to start with
a comment which is
style the social media
content
and then we have that class foota social
media
so here i'm going to style the links
which includes the social media icons
so i'm going to set the color to white
so we have white
then we have the icon
inside the link so i'm going to set the
font size
to one ram which is the default
and then some margin at the left
to separate the icons we have margin
left
i'm going to use one ram
so i'm going to save let's say from the
browser
and there you have it so the next step
now is to make sure that we create a
media
or include a media breakpoint which is
going to target large devices
that is the font size of the icon
so first i'm going to open the inspector
right click and then inspect element so
that you can see
how it looks like on other devices so
inspect element
so here i'm going to include that media
breakpoint and i'm going to copy what we
have here
copy
and then here for large devices we're
going to use 1.7
or 1.6 and then i'm going to save so
let's see from the browser
so you can see now our content is
fitting nicely on a small device
screenwind 360. so i'm going to switch
to another device
like a medium device we have ipad
again you can see our content is fitting
nicely
including the size of the fonts of the
social media icons
so something else is we need to fix
that is the space between at the bottom
where we have the
social media content
so i'm going to close the inspector so
you can see here at the bottom we have
so a big space so we need to fix that
so in html where we have the first
column we're going to add a class
which is mb md0 so we have that class
which is going to fix that so save let's
see
so now you can see we don't have that
space
so uh content is fully responsive and
now we can move to the next
part which is part so on the third part
of the footer
we have the four columns we have the
first column with the company info and
then we have the rest
of the three with the links so let's
work on that so on html i'm going to
create a container for that content
so we have a comment first which is
start
the content for company info
that is for the company info
so that is a comment
so here i'm going to start that
container
which will have a row so we have the row
with a class of text white
and justify content center so we have
that class
so justify content center
and then some margin at the top so here
i'm going to use
margin top three and then some padding
at the bottom so we have padding bottom
three and then tab
so inside the row we need the four
columns
so we're going to start with the first
one which is a bit large
or a bit big than the rest of the three
so that one you're going to to create it
separately so we have
so we're going to start with the call 12
and then for
small devices we're going to use call
small 6.
for large devices you're going to use
call lg
6
so you have six
and then tab
so inside the first column you're going
to add the
heading which is company name and then
they
info about that company and then this
line
so we have h5 with a class of
text capitalized
and a class of fun to it bold
so we have company
name then we need that line
so that one is a hra hr
with a class of bg white
and a class of display inline
block
and then submarine at the bottom so we
have margin bottom
we're going to use four and then tab
and then we need to style it so we have
style
so we have width i'm going to use 60px
and then height
so height i'm going to set that to 2px
2 pixels so i'm going to save let's see
from the browser how it looks like
and there you have it you can see now we
have that text
so let's also add the text
so we have it below the hr so we have
paragraph
with a class of finite large
and then some dummy text so i'm going to
use lorem
17 and then save let's see
and there you have it so
now we have that text i'm going to add
the three
remaining columns
so here i'm going to use call 12
and then for small devices i'm going to
use call
small 6 and then for large devices i'm
going to use
call large 2 that is called lg2
and then some margin at the bottom so we
have mb4
so at the end here i'm going to say
times three because we need three of
them
so hit tab so for the first column
you're going to copy
what we have here that is the heading
the line the two
so i'm going to paste for the three
columns
paste
paste so for the second column we have
heading as
so let's see from the layout we have
products
useful links and then contacts so that
is the order
so we have the second heading so we have
products
and then useful links
and then the that one which is contacts
save let's see how it looks like
and there you have it you can see now we
have the three headings
so the next one now is to add the list
you can see
we have the listing form of the
the listing form of the links so let's
add also
those links
so i'm going to start with the links for
the products so we have another list
with a class of
list inline
and then we need the list items so we
have the li
which will have a link inside and then
some dummy text
so i'm going to use lorem ipsum
and then i'm going to hit tab
so i'm going to duplicate for the three
links
so i'm going to duplicate three times so
we have one
two three so i'm going to save
let's see from the browser how it looks
like
and there you have it you can see now we
have the list or the links
so let's also copy for the useful links
and the contacts
so i'm just going to copy the entire
anode list
to the rest of the columns so for the
useful links
paste and also for the contacts
paste so for these full links you can
see we have a different content from the
layout here you can see
the content is different so i'm going to
copy this and then replace with what you
have
so copy
and then i'm going to pause the video
and then add them
on to useful links
so i've copied everything i'm going to
save let's see from the browser
and there you have it so the next step
now is to style that content
so here i'm going to start by styling
the list items and i'm going to
change the color to white and then
remove the underline
and also have some space to create some
space between the list items
so let's work on that so
on the footer.success at the bottom here
i'm going to start with the comment
which is
style the company info
content so that is a comment
and here i'm going to create a class
which is going to style that list
items so i'm going to call it company
list
so we have company list
so i'm going to set the display to block
so that is the first thing i'm going to
do
so you have block
and then you're going to set the list
style type to none so we have list
type
so i'm going to set that to none and
also
we need to set the position to relative
then we need to style the list items so
we have
the ally inside the list style
so i'm going to set the margin bottom
so i'm going to use 0.5 ram
and then text decoration i'm going to
set to it
to none to remove that underline
and then we need also to style the links
that are inside the list items
so we have the color i'm going to change
that to white or set it to white
and then also text decoration
we need to set that to none
so the next thing now is to add this
class to the list items that we have on
the html
so i'm going to select the ul class that
is an ordered list
for the three so we have the first one
second one
and the third one and then add that
class
company list
and then i'm going to save let's see
save
and there you have it you can see now we
have the list items
so the next thing is to make sure that
once you hover the list or the links
they turn to our primary color so like
what we have here on the layout
so you can see from the left once you
over the links return to that
primary
so on the list again we have the company
list
so we have the hoover
and then i'm going to set the color to
primary
so we have primary and then i'm going to
save let's see
so now if you try to hover the links
you'll see return to that
primary
so the next thing also is to add some
space between
the social media content and the company
info so you can see we need some
enough space or good space like what we
have here on the left
so here on the html i'm going to add
some margin top
where we have that container so i'm
going to add that
class margin top five
so that one will fix that and then save
and there you have it the next step now
is to make sure that our content is
fully responsive so i'm going to open
the inspector
so inspect element so that is how the
content
looks like on a medium device and that's
an ipad screen wind
768 and you can see already the media
breakpoint
is already working so i'm going to
switch to another device
this one will be a small device so let's
go to moto g4
so again here you can see the content is
fitting nicely
on that screen device so let's switch to
another one
so let's go for a larger device ipad pro
so again here you can see the content is
also fitting nicely
and it's fully responsive so even
without
writing a single media breakpoint you
can see
our columns are already creating the
media breakpoints we have created
so the only thing i'm going to do is to
add the
mx auto that is the class for horizontal
centering on the columns that we have
so i'm going to select all the columns
and then add that class
so we have the second one the third one
and then the fourth one so we have that
class mx auto
so i'm going to save let's see
so with that our content now is fully
responsive and you can move on to the
next
part which is part 4 of the footer
that is the bottom footer so on the
bottom footer we have the copyright info
and this is our fourth part of the
footer so let's work on that
so on the html i'm going to create a
container for that content
so let me start with the comment which
is start
the copyright
info
so here i'm going to create a class
called
footer bottom
so inside that we need a cloud container
so i'm going to create that container
and arrow with a class of
text center
and a glass of text white
and then tab
so inside that row we need a class or a
column so i'm going to use
call 12
then inside the column i'm going to
create another class or another
container for the copyright content
so we have footer bottom
and then underscore underscore
copyrights
so from the left here we have the
copyright symbol
and then the text
so i'm going to copy the entire text
and then you're going to start with that
symbol
so we have the code copy
we have it here
and then the text so we have copyright
2021 and then here we need
a link so i'm going to create that link
and then paste and then here also we
need
a link
and then paste so i'm going to save
let's see
how it looks like on the browser
so now you can see we have the text at
the bottom and that is the copyright
info
so the next thing nice to style that
content
so on the footer.success i'm going to
start by setting the background color
for the footer bottom
so let's go to that file and then at the
bottom here i'm going to start with a
comment which is
style the copyrights
footer or basically content
so we have that class footer bottom
so here we have the background color
and i'm going to use black so we have
that color
on the sass file
and then here i'm going to
nest it the way i've done on the html so
we have underscore underscore copyright
so i'm going to set the color
to gray 600 so we have that color
gray 600 and then
phone to it i'm going to set that to
400.
then we need to style the links again
inside the copyright
so we have a link and i am going to set
the color to gray 300.
so we have gray 300.
and then text decoration
we're going to set that to none
so i'm going to save let's see from the
browser
so now that is our copyright so we need
to add some padding
so on the html where we have that class
i'm going to add padding top and padding
bottom so we have padding top
i'm going to set that to five and then
padding bottom
also five and then i'm going to save
let's see again
and there you have it now you can see
it's much better
so the next thing is to create the
hoover
so we need the links to turn to our
primary color
so on the footer inside the link
you're going to create that hoover
effect
so we have hover
so the color we're going to set that to
primary
and then text decoration we're going to
set that to underline
underline so i'm going to save let's see
so now if you try to hover the links
you'll see we have that hoover
which is our primary color
so we need also to make sure that our
footer bottom or copyright info is fully
responsive so i'm going to right click
and inspect elements to see from other
devices
so that is how the content looks like on
a small device
which is with a screen window of 360.
so i'm going to switch to another device
another smaller device pixel 2.
again you can see your content is
fitting nicely on that device
let's go for a medium device
again our content is fitting nicely on
that screen device
so with that we can move on by
creating the next item which is
the back to top button so you can see it
here we have this
back to top so on html i'm going to
create that
button at the end of the footer
so here we have a comment first which is
back to top
button
so we're going to create a link so we
have the link with a class of shadow
and a class of btn primary
to give it that purple color and then
we need to give it that rounded circle
so get what that class which is
rounded circle
so we have tab
and then inside the link we need that
icon
so you can see here from the left
so we have this chevron app icon and
that is the font awesome icon
so here we have the icon with the class
of font or some solid
and the name of that icon is chevron app
so i'm going to save let's see how it
looks like
so on the left here at the bottom left
you can see we have the icon already so
the next thing now is to style it and
make sure that you position it
at the right bottom
so inside the footer
so the bottom here i'm going to start
with the comment which is style
the back top
button
so here i'm going to create a class
which is going to position and style
that button
so i'm going to call it back to top
so i'm going to set the position to
fixed that is the first
property that i'm going to have
so we have fixed and then set the width
and the height of that button so we have
width
i'm going to use the ram and also the
height
also 3 ram
then i'm going to set the position from
right so we have right
1.875 ram
and also the position from bottom
also i'm going to use 1.875
ram
also we need to set the z index
so here i'm going to set a higher number
so we have 99999
and then i'm going to save and then we
need to add this class where we have
that
button so after the rounded circle
paste back to top class and then i'm
going to save let's see from the browser
and there you have it you can see now we
have that rounded button
so the next thing is to position this
icon
at the center of that circle or the
rounded circle
so here going to nest it we have icon
and then we have the color and the font
size
so i'm going to set first the color
so we have color
so white and then the font size
so the front of the font is i'm going to
use one ram
and then we need to position at the
center so we're going to include that
mixing so we have include
and the name of that mixing is absolute
center
and then close i'm going to save let's
see
and there you have it now you can see
you have the icon
at the center of that rounded circle or
the button
so now if you click the button you'll be
able to scroll to the top
and you can see the button is already
working
so click again and there you have it
so with that we are done with that part
and we've come to the end of this
project if you made it to this far
congratulations
hope you've learned a lot from this
project and if you have questions
please post them on the comments thanks
for watching